Hello everybody, we've been waiting for Mint Fantome because
she was late again.
Are you saying that?
Are you typing that?
Did we give her a countdown?
I just swapped over.
Oh my god!
You don't even know how to say my name right.
What do you mean?
Mint Fantome.
Hi Doki, what are you talking about?
It's not May anymore.
But yes, I had to get ahead of the story.
I didn't even give her a countdown that we're swapping.
I was like, boom, does, hello everybody, Min is the reason
why we're late.
I have literal timestamps.
I sent the game to you at 205.
Yeah, because if you don't have a game picked out already.
I thought we were playing the first game.
So I bought the first game.
first game and then it was like you should play this game i
was like you know what because you're such a good friend you
were so full of you didn't buy the first game at all you
didn't you typed in the chat you said you typed in the chat
you were like i bought two games and then literally
immediately you said i didn't buy two games yeah proof i
said that you seem to be making stuff up right now no i the
people will believe me because i'm an honest ghost oh yeah
what do you mean i'm so honest everything i say is the truth
and will always be the truth it's like those what is it like
the the things that are just like the person to the left
yeah the one tells lies the other tells truth which one is
it to get through the door
and they're both liars no but yeah we i have i think i'm
being haunted guys by something definitely not her though i
don't know no never all right today we are playing fears to
fathom um which one was it that you told me to play the wood
burry getaway is it actually actually spooky I don't know
the last with the scratch Creek one maybe it's because we
spent like two hours on cow clicker it was one hour wait
actually was it two hours it was like one and a half hours
of cow clicker how long was that yeah that's it was I think
if we didn't play one and a half hours of cow clicker we
would have finished that game within an hour it was one hour
of you watching tv oh yes that's true guys we had it we had
to pat the time guys it was a oh boy don't you want to get
your the stream ended earlier you don't want that did you
cow click but i regret to inform you there's no cow clicker
there's no cow clicker was that was that like the first game
they started to experiment yeah yeah oh that is what it was
like what if we add cow clicker to the game that was a good
experimentation it was that was it was a good gamba honestly
i kind of want to like leave a good review yeah you should
yeah just be like add cow clicker too for their next
installment i demand a sequel to cow clicker yeah we need
more cow clicker actually every game should have i'll be
like nine out of ten should have had the game should have
been 90 cow clicker wasn't there wait was it only cow
clicker there another game i can't remember it was just cow
clicker there's cow clicker and we're texting each other and
no cows in this one boo five oh ten there was no cows i'm
booting up the game right now all right all right all right
i don't know if sound guys are live on my stream but let me
know how the sound is also share the game to me oh yeah give
you like a 10 second speedily by watching this stream you'll
be like what do i do and i'm like i don't even know where
you are like give me 10 seconds yeah yeah i would like a new
patch notes please to remove cow sun uh please nerf cow sun
yeah honestly uh cow sun kind of broken yeah i would like
you to uh nerf cow sun please oh my god it does look like
you're haunting me what the does it really yeah all right
let's see is there anything i have to change these saint i
didn't know my fps count toilet sounds you might want to
turn off the eating sounds how bad am i annoying wow i want
to know what that sounds like okay you can go for it all
right oh yeah there's no sensitivity oh there's oh thanks
for credit thank you guys does this guy have a patreon so i
can get myself in the game It can be chill as art.
Open a Patreon so we can be in the game.
I mean, we could just email them and be like, look, here's
our story.
We did say that last time.
All right, I'll email them right now.
Okay.
All right.
This is actually an email drafting stream.
Yeah, this is an email drafting stream right now.
All right, what should we say?
I'll use my business email.
All right, two.
Dear Mr. Fathom.
all right i actually you know what i give up you should open
chat gpt and ask
we have like like our chat help us all right what can we see
dear john fathom it's like madlibs it's like yeah dear mr
john fathom uh we love your game so much you could say i
played every single one.
He definitely knows who that is.
Let's see.
And boy, do we have a story for you.
Wait, what's the subject line?
It's got to be like a real kit thing.
Right?
Mint Fantome and Doki Bird story.
Please put us in your game.
The card is the subject he's going to delete it immediately.
No, there's no way.
There's no way he's going to...
We're famous.
I'm trying to think of anything.
Delete him.
I write that.
I know, right.
We're famous V-Tubers.
All right, what else should we say?
Oh, I never...
Oh, wait.
I never thought it could happen to us.
but it did so bad I was haunted by a ghost wait he doesn't
do ghost oh he doesn't do ghost no he does like home
invasion stuff oh I was home invaded I was home I was home
invaded I was home invaded by what by a ghost by a ghost He
doesn't do ghosts!
It's, but it's still...
By a girl pretending to be a ghost.
Oh, wait.
You're not real?
Am I real?
He doesn't do ghosts, but then...
So then you can't be... You have to be...
Oh, you could say...
I was like living in your walls.
Oh.
Pretending to be a ghost.
Pretending to be a ghost and living...
And living in my walls.
Okay.
Um, I thought I was going crazy.
You were?
And while I was streaming, she would...
What would you do?
I would...
I would pour water down your back.
She would pour water.
I think we have to delete this email.
What do you mean you have to delete the email?
I think he's going to delete the email.
He reads the first line.
Wait, okay.
Wait, I'll link my YouTube link first of this stream.
Oh, good, good.
Of this stream.
Okay.
Okay, I'll post.
streams.
Alright, this one.
And then where's my other fear stream?
There we go.
There's the other one.
Do mine.
Do mine so we know.
Okay, okay.
And then...
Okay, the cow one.
I'll do yours.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Mint Fear.
And...
Yeah, for context, you know?
For getting context.
Yeah.
Alright, let's see.
I'll do that.
And then...
All right.
This stream.
I was streaming.
She was, and, and while I was streaming, she would pour
water down my back.
I thought I was just really sweaty.
But then it happened a little too often.
I went to the doctor and no one could explain my symptoms.
and no one I went to doctors and no one could explain my
symptoms horrifying it was horrifying I couldn't sleep I
couldn't eat yeah that's good that's good that's good so you
cried every night and I but I didn't cry I'm a big girl and
i'm really strong i'm a big girl and i'm really strong
this guy he's not gonna read half the emails get deleted no
he'll read it he'll read it he'll read it okay okay oh also
say that we're cute be like we are too cute you know girls
to put in your game you're the you're you're my home invader
though Oh, okay, okay.
My home invader was pretty cute, though.
So I guess it was okay.
Okay, this is good.
This is good.
Okay, okay, okay.
How do we end this?
How do we end?
Um, we...
We...
um well uh you could do an exorcism and i leave your house
oh okay the front door at some point at some point i called
an exorcist yeah yeah that's good that's good exorcist how
do you spell okay i spelled it right exorcist he burned some
idle shit what the fuck was what is that
Where's that for my game?
Oh, it might be me.
Hold on.
Is that for me?
What is that?
Is that vacuum?
What the fuck was going on?
Oh my god, it's the exorcist.
It's the exorcist coming in.
He burned.
Okay.
He started vacuuming.
I think it's a leaf blower.
He started using a leaf blower.
Oh my god, it's a true story!
This is a true story!
It's a true story.
He started using a leaf blower and blowing...
I'll just view it until he's gone.
No, keep it going.
It's the immersion, Mint.
It's the immersion.
Yeah, Luigi's getting mint.
It's like vacuuming Mint up.
And blowing out some...
Blowing out blue arc.
Oh, wait, no.
Idle.
Idle shit.
I don't know.
I don't know what they're called.
what started blowing out idle shit out the door and my home
invaded
ran for ran for it i was gonna say blue archived and idle
shit out the door
no one will know what that means all right then you guys
think a pen lights started how do i end the sentence i
called an exorcist and he started using a leaf blower and
what and it blew away her metal gear solid collection let's
do that and it blew away her metal gear solid collection out
my front door i heard A loud scream and a 50-year-old woman
came bursting out of my wad.
What?
With a maid outfit.
That was not flattering.
Dude.
Age.
Out of their pot.
That was a little too...
A little...
How do I say it?
That word.
She was definitely...
The outfit was definitely too young for her.
It is flattering.
okay wearing me okay i didn't say she was she was cute so i
didn't mind it so i should say wearing made outfit and even
if she was a hag it did look good on her
50 years young moe had no she can't defend herself she's
muted they have 50 years of young 50 plus years young all
right it has ascended she has where did she go where did she
go all right all right this is what her story is right now
fathom we love your game so much mint played every single
one and boy do we have a story for you i never thought it
could happen to us but it did i was home invaded by a girl
pretending to be a ghost in living my walls i thought i was
going crazy and while i was streaming she would pour water
down my back i thought i was just really sweaty because i
love wait because i'm really good at competitive games but
then it happened a little too often I went to doctors and no
one could explain my symptoms it was horrifying I couldn't
sleep I couldn't eat but I didn't cry every night I'm a big
girl I'm really strong my home invader is pretty cute though
so I guess it was okay at some point I call an exorcist we
started using a leaf bluer and it blew away my year solid
collection out my front door i heard a loud scream and a 50
plus year young woman came bursting out of my walls wearing
a maid outfit and even if she was what you call a hag it did
look good on her all right what all right what how do i end
the story guys how do i how do i end this we're sending this
story to mr john fathom so um oh but but before um i closed
the door i took out my phone and decided to play my favorite
game cal clicker to I really like this version because they
nerfed cow son
because they the devs finally nerfed cow son so it's so much
so it's more balanced um than the original cow clicker
I'm back you're back all right you want to hear the story so
far Yes, yes.
The leaf blower guy.
I went down to ask him to stop.
You actually asked him to stop?
Yeah, but he said he couldn't.
He's like, please.
I'm in a very important meeting right now.
Yes, please.
Please understand.
It's a very important business meeting.
I'm in a call with my international contacts from around the
world.
This is a $5 million deal.
Sorry.
Yeah, he doesn't understand.
The world peace is hinging on this.
this meeting yeah if you do not stop right now there will be
world war three there all right you want to hear the story
so far yeah okay so the subject line is still tbd so like
it's still work in progress it's mint phantome and dokeybird
story please put us in your game um okay okay okay uh dear
mr john fathom and that linked are to youtube streams we
love your games so much mint has played every single one of
them and boy do we have a story for you i never thought it
could happen to us but it did i was home invaded by a girl
pretending to make ghosts and living in my walls i thought i
was going crazy and while i was streaming she would pour
water down my back i thought i was just really sweaty
because i'm really good at competitive games but then it
happened a little too often i went to the doctors and no one
could It was horrifying.
I couldn't sleep.
I couldn't eat.
I didn't cry every night.
I'm a big girl and I'm really strong.
My home invader was pretty cute though, so I guess it was
okay.
At some point, I called an exorcist.
He started using a leaf blower and it blew away my Metal
Gear Solid collection out my front door.
I heard a loud scream and a 50 plus year young woman came
bursting out of my walls.
Why should she have to be 50?
Maybe that's closer.
That's closer.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's closer.
Yeah, right?
Keem bursting out of my walls, wearing a maid outfit, and
even if she was what we call a hag, it did look good on her.
Did you say it did or did it?
I said it did look good on, because I said earlier that she
was cute.
So now I should, like, make a reference to why I thought she
was cute, you know?
True, true, true, true.
i closed the door i took out my phone and decided to play my
favorite game cow clicker too i really like this version
because the devs finally nerfed cow son so it was more
balanced than the original cow clicker yeah i gave them a
way to add cow clicker in there you know yeah good good good
good idea good idea all right how do i end this after well
you wait yeah you already i already left oh yeah so after
she maybe i could come back oh that's true Oh wait, after
she left
After she left I never saw her again It really spooked me
But sometimes While in my room In my room I would hear The
sounds of moose Coming from the walls I wonder if she also
Okay, what did she also, liked CalClicker too.
What if I come back as a cow?
You come back, you're dressed up as a cow instead.
I'm like, click me, click me, moo.
Click me, moo, click me, moo.
Thank you for reading this story.
We hope this inspires you for your- From here to the day for
you.
I think it will, I think it will.
Next day game.
Dokeybird and Mint Fantome
All right, let's see For those who want to read the story at
their own I don't know, I don't know our subject line should
be Mint Fantome and Dokeybird story Please put us in your
game Should that, what should I think that it sounds too
desperate Yeah, yeah, I feel like it sounds just a little
too desperate Or what ideas, what other What subject line
should we do, guys?
We could, you could say like Doki Bird and Fanto huge
professional streamers with a super scary story.
Huge professional streamers with a super scary story.
There we go.
Wait, I like that.
I like that.
Let me show it to Let me show it to chat and then you can
read read it this time.
You can read the full story.
Alright, here it is, chat.
We'll have a read-along from Mint.
Wait, where'd you put it?
Wait, I'll send it to you.
I just had to upload it real quick.
Yeah, yeah, this is good, this is good.
Yeah, yeah.
Alright, read it.
Oh, I read it?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What, you just read it?
Yeah, but then I didn't read the full thing.
Like, now it's fully completed.
It's your turn to narrate this.
Okay, okay, okay.
Dear Mr. John Fathom, YouTube link, YouTube link.
We love your games so much.
Mint played every single one of them, and boy, do we have a
story for you.
I never thought it could happen to us, but it did.
I was home invaded by a girl pretending to be a ghost and
living in my walls.
I thought I was going crazy, and while I was streaming, she
would pour water to my back.
This really does sound like a Mad Lib story.
I thought I was just really sweaty because I'm really good
at competitive games, but then it happened a little too
often.
I went to the doctors and no one could explain my symptoms.
It was horrifying.
I couldn't sleep.
I couldn't eat.
But I didn't cry every night.
I'm a big girl and I'm really strong.
That's right.
Yeah.
My home invader was pretty cute, though, so I guess it was
okay.
At some point, I called an exorcist.
Well, how do you know what she looks like?
Well, like, well, it's like me retelling the story, you
know?
So, like, I'm just remembering, oh, yeah, you know, like,
oh, you know, I didn't mind.
Like, and I didn't really mind it because she was pretty
cute, you know?
Okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
At some point, I called an exorcist.
He started using a leaf blower, and it blew away my Metal
Gear Solid collection out my front door.
I heard a loud scream, and a 60-plus-year-old woman.
You're young.
Oh, sorry.
You spelled woman wrong.
It's woman.
He won't take us seriously, don't keep me.
Yeah, sorry, sorry.
I need to make sure I spell checked everything.
Yeah.
Came bursting out of my walls, wearing a maid outfit, and
even if she was what we call a hag, it did look good on her.
But before I closed the door, I took out my phone and
decided to play my favorite game, Cow Clicker 2.
I really like this version because the devs finally nerfed
cow son, so it was more balanced than the original cow
clicker.
After she left, I never saw her again.
It really spooked me, but sometimes in my room, I would hear
the sounds of moose coming from the wall.
I wonder if she also liked cow clicker, too.
Thank you for reading this story.
We hope this inspires you for your next game.
Regards Doki Bird and Mint Phantom.
I think this is good.
I think, yeah, I think this is really good.
Oh, I think it's good.
make this story into a game we would voice act it for free
we would we would voice act it for free if you don't put
this game put the story into your game we will voice act we
will still voice act for free let us voice act your game
John Fathom for free in any game you make Whoa, whoa, whoa,
this is huge.
If you need us to moo in Cow Clicker 2, we will moo.
Wait a second.
Donkey Bird says she will moo.
Only if it's Cow Clicker 2.
Only if he makes Cow Clicker 2, we'll be like moo, moo, moo,
moo, moo.
Any role, we will be the cow.
She keeps saying we, but it's definitely emphasized Doki
Bird.
We will take any role because we love your games.
And we love cow clicker.
Especially mint.
And we especially love cow clicker.
There we go.
Wait, did you type all that?
Yeah.
Oh, whoa.
Thank you for reading this story.
We hope this inspires you for your next game If you happen
to make this story in a game, we will voice acted for free
If you don't put this story into your game, we will voice
act for free in any game you make We will take any roles
because we love your games especially mint and we especially
love cloud clicker Cow clicker.
Yeah All right, I'm sending it Okay, all right Oh, I didn't
even specify the recipient I didn't even put like who I'm
sending oh it's fears to fathom stories they're like please
please specify the recipient there was like nobody at the
two side you got too eager yeah i got too eager all right
stories at gmail.com fears to fathom stories i gotta make
sure it's like spelled the email correctly spheres to fathom
stories all right send oh message has been sent yeah all
right let's see if he leaves us on red or delete your email
we're in our voice acting era yeah this is our voice acting
era right now uh we have experience so uh mint was in the
what was it called the needy girl streamer overload gate uh
anime and i was in the game and you know we practice
professional voice actors now we are we are that's like huge
yeah we're so big in the voice we're like up-and-comers in
the voice acting industry yeah actually yeah keep a name it
could keep a lookout for our names and any upcoming anything
exactly also somebody said vod watchers skip 40 minutes of
banding um the stream did not start at 3 p.m so it did not
start on the hour you are very wrong.
Also, this is part of the game.
This is part of the experience.
We're going to make references to our story and then you
would be so confused because you skipped the first 40
minutes.
Right?
What if he patches the game and updates it with the story?
Yeah, exactly.
It just suddenly there's like, they just add CalClick or two
in this game.
Yeah.
Are you ready?
Next scene, this is not a fan fiction It happened.
It actually happened?
It's non-fiction.
It's a true story.
Right, Min?
Yeah, exactly.
She was in my walls.
And 60 years old.
And 60 plus years old.
I'm sorry, I forgot the plaz.
This is a true story based on true events.
All right, let's play this.
Get away
What how let me see if I have audio people around oh Yeah, I
see offline
It's okay.
I got you I got you all right right you got me you got me
Yep chat you guys got get me.
I don't I don't know if anybody's alive All right space to
get up what you Hold on, I'm gonna mute you and I'm gonna
listen to your stream.
Oh wait, audio people are alive!
Okay, it's okay, man!
It's okay!
Get back in here!
I'm in the office.
I think it sounds good, actually.
Whoa.
Like I said, I really need a cup of coffee.
Okay.
Yeah, you need a cup of coffee.
Oh, is this where the girl in the wall is gonna start
moving?
Moo!
Why are you at work so late?
Well, I have to catch up on stuff.
I have so much backlog!
Get your coffee!
Where the fuck is... Where's... Oh, there's the coffee.
Okay, I needed to prepare a cup of coffee.
Wow, it's a like legitimate curing.
It's like... Oh.
Oh, good job.
Oh, I needed water.
All right We hear it from the distance.
Yeah You hear it guys.
I think I'm being haunted Oh my god, I have a cow my cow
needs to be milk So cows go into heat What?
Where did that go from?
Because like what if they're just mooing a lot because you
know no usually when they're mooing a lot It's because they
need to be milked because we domesticated cows so much that
they can't milk themselves Really?
They're like pigeons domestication is you know like how like
domesticated horses Needs to have their nails trimmed and
everything because yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well, I heard that's because they just don't run enough like
in general Yeah, but also what they grow the nails grow so
fast that like even when you're running alive doesn't help a
lot Where the fuck do you put your cups?
Do you not put your cups in the cupboards?
That's why they're called cupboards.
You have a cup.
No, you grabbed it.
Oh my god.
Well, I thought they wanted an acrylic cup, you know?
I thought they wanted a glass cup.
No, you grabbed the cup.
Put a lid on it.
On it.
So thorough.
Yeah.
What if I don't remember to sip?
It's so hot!
She's burning her tongue.
I'm gonna use my... the restroom?
While I'm drinking?
I just sipped it.
Oh, weird bathroom.
Keep sipping, keep sipping.
Sipping in the bathroom.
Sip on the toilet.
That's true.
I'm gonna use the men's bathroom too.
Oh no, I picked my bathroom.
Gina through.
Oh my god, I can A-my cup.
it and we do it in the throw it in the toilet that's true oh
nice oh come on it won't go in it's not me ref it's not me
there's a visible wall she's i just don't let her audition
for basketball you guys i was a i played ball guys that we
need to revise we need to revise the story like an amendment
to it like reply to me like um okay that was in come on
you're throwing it too much of the right okay if I angle it
here no what if I angle it okay this is good enough oh
disgusting oh I didn't close the door yeah Let me pee Press
E to pee Okay, there we go E to pee E to pee Oh, you have a
P meter It's good Bladder Halfway empty, everybody She's
going She's peeing Oh, I'm peeing I'm peeing She's peeing
She's peeing Right now Fastest pee in the west Our sound gap
Is everything good?
Hang on, I got my cup Ah!
Wait, why aren't you doing the women's bathroom?
I'm so sorry, ma'am.
I didn't know you were in here.
It's okay.
How are you?
How are you after staring the hell out of me?
Yeah, you're in the women's bathroom.
You're like, how are you?
Not too bad, ma'am.
I was just finishing up my cleaning rounds.
Oh, it's the janitor.
I like to clean late because it's pretty quiet this hour.
You're working late again, huh?
yeah you young folks sure do put in the hours make sure to
take care of yourself you too oh oh you stop I tripped I
tripped I tripped oh my god he's gonna kill us he's gonna
kill us clean up your own mess he's not gonna kill us look
look Oh my god.
Look at that face, though.
He didn't even hold the door open for you.
He hates you.
You think this clean... Oh, no.
See?
He's fine.
He's repeating them.
See?
Oh, now he doesn't even...
Am I getting cancelled for harassing a minimum... I know,
right?
This poor guy's just trying to do his job.
You're a fancy schmancy.
You got your desk and your cubicle.
That's right.
I'm up He's got to clean the bathrooms.
Someone has to do it.
You're up for promotion.
I don't think you're up for promotion.
You're working.
You're working like at 4 a.m.
Can I make another coffee?
Oh, I can't.
I'm not allowed to.
Just make a whole mess of the kitchen.
You should just throw everything around.
You're right.
He's paid by the hour anyway.
Oh, they're unlimited.
Nice.
You could cover the entire floor with cups.
Can you pick up anything else?
Like the snacks on the table and stuff?
Oh, I can.
Oh, you can.
Oh, I should bring this.
I should, I should need these chips in my office.
Yeah, you should.
Yeah, I should grab that.
It's a good idea.
Oh, I got a call.
Got business call for my very important business.
This is your promotion.
My very important, super serious job.
Hello.
Mushy, mushy.
Moshi Moshi Answer the Answer the phone I saw I did I think
you have to like turn Go over Cindy Harper Harper Hey harp
it's Mike That could be us We could be Mike right now Yeah
that could be us Hey harp it's Mike This is um Mr. John
Fallon This is our audition tape for Mike Alright you go
first I've been trying to call yourself For the last two
hours I've been trying to call yourself for the the last two
hours it keeps going to voicemail is everything all right
that's a good line we should keep that in we should keep
that cut that should be the the main one the pacing the
pacing was you know it could have been better but yeah
that's true but i feel like i feel like you know um you you
got the vibe of mike though you know like you you embodied
mike right there i think oh i felt i felt like him actually
feel mike off of that voice okay all right yeah my phone's
been acting Snap.
I was starting to think maybe you were ignoring me.
No, it even...
No, it even cut out on the client earlier.
I'm just kidding.
I think we're getting the part.
I think they have to cast us.
It's supposed to be an awkward laugh.
Yeah.
I mean, like...
I felt the awkward to listen to.
Yeah, I felt it too.
Good, good, good.
Anyway, what are you still doing at work?
It's getting kind of late.
That's a mic that we're so in.
I mean, I think we're...
This is so good.
We're so good at this.
Call me Mike Phantom from now on, please.
She's now Mike Phantom.
she's gonna get a name change and let you go get it legally
changed her YouTube channel be Mike Phantom Mike Phantom
just more overtime damn that sounds rough good thing I
called to cheer you up oh boy nobody asked you nobody about
our trip did you get a chance to book the rental house wait
is this my boyfriend he wanted to see you and Nora oh and
Nora oh who's Nora no oh you seem a bit annoyed about me
calling seriously Harper this is a bad time I mean they're
calling my work number yeah during my work hours um hello I
am trying to work my ass off for this promotion right now
yeah Harper I know I'm sorry if I was being pushy just
struggling a little lately no worries Harper I don't want to
stress you out as As long as you book it tonight, I think
it'll be fine.
Why don't you do it?
Yeah, why don't you do it?
Why am I doing it?
Oh, because he wants to mooch off of my money.
He wants to use my credit card to deposit it under my name.
He knows we're getting a big, big, big promotion.
Yeah, yeah, he knows.
Hey.
I was thinking since we both live in the city, maybe I could
pick you up and ride together.
Oh, you're trying to.
I think Mike likes Sydney.
likes her.
I think you like likes her.
Ooh.
You know, live on gas and relive the good old days.
Just a little bit of Mike and Sydney time before Nora.
You can't decline?
Yeah, I know.
I can't say no.
I just say sure.
Mike and Sydney.
And Nora.
And Nora?
I guess I'll let you go back to work there.
Oh, yeah, please.
One more thing.
What is it?
There's a ghost in my walls.
Yeah.
Can you book the rental?
Please make sure to keep it under $100 a night.
That's my credit card.
Nora and I were talking and she's been on a pretty tight
budget.
Oh.
Things haven't been going very well for her.
It hangs up.
Oh, dang.
Telling Nora's business to us even.
Damn.
She wanted to keep that private between you and Mike.
Whoops.
Or do I do?
Should I hang up or should I say sure I found something
affordable?
Am I gonna be a bitch or I'll be a bitch, yeah Look at that
cat on the desk Oh, that's our cat It's a cute cat He's
handsome, he's a handsome cat Would you think there's games
on this computer?
I don't know, I tried to click on it There's no cow clicker
too Oh, I threw the chips too close to the PC Now I can't
pick my chips up No Hell, I eat my chips It's all right, I
still have coffee.
Am I supposed to work now?
Like, or do I not just...
The game should tell you what to do.
Oh, I have to book the cabin.
All right, there we go.
Oh, here we go.
There you go.
Oh, fatal error on your recycle bin.
Wait, what's the aliens?
Your type invader.
Oh, my.
I'm so good at this.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my.
Look at me go.
You're getting those little guys.
Oh, my God.
It's like typing of the...
tiny that's right get out of here yeah that's my apm right
there oh oh oh oh it's fine it's the worst oh there's four
of them four of them oh not that was fast nice zero nice
that's right 92 percent accuracy annihilate these guys oh
there's oh oh my god he's running He's running no more.
I got his legs.
Rod watchers Get you out Yeah, how far did you get in this
one man, huh?
I think I completed it 100% accurately I'm sure you did Hey,
I'm a former I'm a former office lady don't don't
Don't doubt me I don't know what's your APM huh what's APM
oh it's just wait is that that's it that's it you should
know if that was it if you completed it all right new world
record oh is that my company Apache 120 thousand dollars
okay wait DVA hub is 500 holy no 500 yeah we gotta we gotta
keep that contact in hey what about apex apex innovate apex
legends innovate it says no no no apex for you well it was
like nine yeah put in like yeah yeah and then change it to
yes change it to yes yes confirmed confirmed text score
amazing amazing remark we should go with this one yeah yeah
this one commissioned me uh looks you are working yeah oh
you can do browser I think is where you yeah yeah oh yeah oh
oh I read the cow I'm feeling unlucky you probably you're in
this game i'm unable to execute my fucking pc all right they
hold you a lot they have everything locked down on these
like work computers you know oh that's true that's true they
have like a uh what's it called like the sensor the firewall
yeah yeah yeah oh i think we should go to peaceful cabin
peaceful cabin private room in nature cozy lodge entire
guest house open villa oh I think I like get that one yeah I
like that's 11 yeah I'm booking it was over our budget no
just tell them that you'll cover I'll cover for them yeah
it's only 8 20 p.m wait it looked like 5 a.m oh my god I'll
cover for her I'll cover the I'm getting a promotion you
know I see my me and Apex Innovate?
Also, go up.
Okay, the reviews aren't so bad on the place that we have to
get.
But that one is not good.
That one's like, that's just a, that's just a shed right
there with like a chair.
Oh, for that price, hell no.
Yeah, I mean, this is a house.
I mean, that's nice.
But there must be a reason why, because there's only two
reviews.
Two reviews, that's what I was going to say, only two
Yeah, there must be a reason why it's that cheap compared to
everything else.
A lot of these have pretty bad reviews.
Except for the most expensive one.
I mean, does it come with a guitar?
Wait, go look at the one with the bad reviews, what the
pictures look like.
Oh, yeah, this one?
That looks like that is actually just...
I like how majority of the picture is, like, look at this
garden.
I know, right?
Look at the inside of the house.
It looks like a Sims house.
It's like the starter house.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god, that's one has a...
God damn it, Nora!
Nora, we could have gone to literally...
We could have gone...
There was a pool here, Nora.
We could have had a barbecue.
Alright, I guess we booked this one.
Yeah, it looks like a murder house.
Murder house.
I mean, at least it has Wi-Fi.
Oh, okay, good.
You can keep playing your games.
Yeah.
hey i'm assuming you get hundreds if not thousands of
stories send daily including ours we should have we should
have we should have made our like this should been the
template oh my god we should have so he would read ours oh
my god we're so stupid we should have made the beginning
sound like a real story it did sound like a real story
you're right you're right you're right and it was so real it
was.
So I'll give you a basic rundown of something that happened
to me.
I'm sorry, some of it is written weird, but I was rushed.
When I was in my early 20s, I worked at a big consulting
firm in my city.
Life at the firm was a constant juggle of deadlines, client
meetings, and trying to prove my worth, which didn't leave
much room for leisure, let alone a social life.
The job paid well, sure, but expense of my mental peace.
I'm Sydney Harper, and the story takes place during one of
those days.
Wait, do you think our story will be in the game?
I'm Jokey Bird, and Mint Phantom, and the story takes place.
She would pour water down my back.
But it was okay, because she was pretty, she was kind of
cute.
One of my college friends, Mike, suggested that we take a
weekend getaway to rural Vermont, which sounded like a
perfect break from the cycle of work.
And my other friend, Nora, was quick to jump on board as
well.
The plan was simple.
We ran a small cabin, closed our shift early on Friday,
leave, and be back on Monday.
Mike came to pick me up.
Alright, Mike.
Two days later.
Okay, the spooky stuff didn't happen in my office.
Is this Mike?
Oh, on his PSP?
Oh, oh, he's really happy.
He's very happy.
Oh, there's Mike.
Mike is calling you.
How do I pick it up?
Oh, do I not want to pick him up?
All right.
Fuck you, Mike.
Never mind.
Pulling to the garage door now.
You down to clown?
How do I look at my message?
Wait, you didn't even talk to the guy in the elevator.
I don't think he cares.
He was looking at you with his PSP.
thought it was so cool talk to him talk to him tell him say
hello hello oh afternoon quite chilly day i like how you
don't want to talk to him but but you instigate the
conversation i've seen you around but i haven't had a chance
to introduce myself i'm gil i'm cindy it's nice to meet you
you're on the 10th floor right i'm on the 8th wait how do
you know that yeah how do you know that How does he know
that?
How does he know?
I was in the elevator first.
Yeah.
I've just seen you a few times getting off at the 10th floor
when I'm home late from work.
Oh, yeah.
What do you do?
Yeah, what do you do?
Yeah.
Me?
I'm a software engineer.
What about you?
Wow.
A software engineer.
Big shot over here.
He's a big shot.
I bet he works at Microsoft.
Wow.
Yeah, we're at a consulting firm downtown.
It sucks to be him.
Is that a nerd I see?
Anyways, what?
What's wrong with my...
Is he judging my career?
I'll have you know.
I got Apex Innovate into our firm.
I'm a great rest of your day.
Nine million trillion dollars.
Nine million trillion dollars right there.
Yeah.
How do you get some groceries before the show starts?
Snow starts.
I was going to say show.
Bye.
Oh, there's Mike.
Hey, Mike.
Pick up my fucking suitcase.
Yeah, be a gentle poop.
Hi.
Um, hug.
Hello.
Oh, that's so awkward.
That's so what?
Oh, I'm sorry.
What do you mean?
I'm sorry.
My Mike you don't why don't you hug me like you missed me oh
my god just test to see how I like to see you smell first
fair enough before the record I shout oh yeah wait you're
Mike oh fair enough before the record I showered just for
the occasion nothing is too good for Sydney Harper I just
dot dot dot why did you shower just for you should shower
normally too oh he's jealous guy you were just talking to uh
that was gail from the eighth floor yeah so specific he's a
software engineer yeah where do you work at yeah Mike he's
also 6 foot 5 yeah and he owns a PSP yeah it was yeah
Where's your PSP, Mike?
Mike.
Interesting.
Thanks for picking me up.
Wouldn't have it any other way.
It'll be nice to have company on the way.
This old truck brings back so many memories.
I like how you can just not respond to him.
Yeah.
Just be passive aggressive.
I know.
Right?
This bad boy has been through a lot.
Even the game was like, yeah, no, dot, dot, dot.
Or you should be a gentleman and take it for me.
I've been working the whole time.
You're the one that wanted me to go to the cabin.
You could just throw your stuff in the back and we'll be it.
Get on our way.
All right.
Oh.
There we go.
First try.
All right, then, harp.
Are you ready to hit the road?
Where's Nora?
Yeah, where's Nora?
Yeah, where is she?
I thought it was you, me, and Nora.
Yeah.
She'll meet us there.
Nora's not coming, is she?
He killed Nora.
Nora is in your suitcase.
Yeah, Nora's in the other suitcase.
Nora is in the suitcase.
The route through the city would have been a detour for her
anyway.
But we're the three musketeers.
We're the three musketeers!
It's you, me, and Nora!
Yeah!
Alright then, harp.
Oh, wait, I'm on the other side.
No, you're driving this thing.
Alright, here we go.
I hope you can drive manual.
4.26.
Wait, but we got off at 8.
Have we been driving the whole night?
I think so, yeah.
Oh, it's snowing, too.
Oh, it's so dark.
It was starting to snow.
That was actually a gift from my coworker, Ricky.
Oh, the little bobby head.
I clicked on it.
Said he found it at a garage sale, and it reminded me of him
somehow i can see a little bit resemblance it's the cowboy
spirit i guess yeah mehah
oh we got some oh not much of a signal when you were out
here this far just keep that right on the road mike oh yeah
you don't need to look at me while you talk yeah just gonna
leave the static on
What?
X-ray 3, United November?
Harp, isn't it weird?
We used to dream about escaping our college, and now we are
here.
Wait, here we are.
Trying to escape from the life we wanted to live.
Oh, I got...
Rick Wilson!
We couldn't wait to get out into the real world, and now we
have to pay taxes.
maybe we just didn't know how much the real world would you
know wow suck sometimes that's real deep deep Mike damn Mike
why am I looking at that bus I don't know did you see that
school bus why was it so weird yeah what a school bus back
there by the old house what someone made used to be a school
bus driver how's that weird yeah that's not that's not that
weird yeah is that weird maybe it's a project you know
someone's idea of turning it into their tiny home on wheels
or something i've read people do that on the internet wow
you're so you're so knowledgeable oh shit goodbye oh my god
this is why you need to look at the road exactly
that was close it came out of nowhere it came out nowhere
mike you know i've read on the internet this guy is always
reading on the internet that a native american lore seeing a
deer cross your path is like getting a message from the
universe what does that mean oh he closed my don't forget to
check your text oh i can look oh i could have picked up the
call okay i didn't realize it was escape oh yeah yeah yeah
um thanks for booking my i'm rick your host let me know you
have any questions and feel free to my god please rick i'm
still reading Feel free to- I'm David, why?
How far is it now?
Are we even close?
Mike?
Oh, sorry.
Sorry, I'm getting pinged.
Oh my gosh.
It should be about an hour and a half from here.
Mike?
Mike just stares at you.
Silence.
He doesn't look at the road anymore.
I was like, Mike?
Mike?
You know, driving through the snow feels kind of like we're
traveling through the intergalactic space.
What the fuck do you mean, Mike?
Look at the way the snowflakes swirl around the head.
Look at the road, Mike!
I know, distractive driving, distractive driving.
It's like stars and galaxies rushing past us.
Oh my gosh, so romantic.
This is why Nora's not here.
She didn't want to put up with Mike's bullshit.
It's kind of beautiful.
Mike, please.
Mike, by the way, the person that we're renting this house
or is trying to contact us.
All right, let me...
Oh, oh, my God, I will definitely know what he said.
You guys, remember when we were playing The Last Fears to
Fathom and it said the other person was still reading?
I think this is definitely showing who the other...
other person that kept you reading distracting me and
interrupting us.
Oh, pizza.
Moe's pizza.
Well, I want some Moe's pizza.
Is it made by Moe?
It has to be.
You know, Harp, I gotta tell you.
These new GPS systems are something else.
This pizzeria is exactly where it appeared on my GPS.
Oh my god.
It's like Lord Lord living in the future.
Whoa.
I'm just hungry.
I think I eat.
could eat a whole horse pizza myself.
Me?
Dot dot dot.
All right then, harp.
Operation Pizza Pit Stop is a go.
Prepare to land.
This guy's such a nerd.
That is such a nerd, yeah.
You think he's in us?
I hope not.
No, I don't think so.
He's into intergalactic space travel.
True, true, true.
He's into intergalactic space women.
Oh, he's holding the door for you.
Come on in harp.
Oh, thank you.
Oh, oh, no.
No, no, no.
Wait, this is Keso.
Wait, I think it is.
We can be on the game.
We can be on TV.
It's so cold out here.
I can't feel my hands.
I mean, like, the studio should have really brought some
snow gear instead of buying that new coffee machine.
I'm sure you'll be fine.
You can have some coffee when you get back to the store.
Yeah, no, that is him!
That's his voice!
That's him!
I recognize a Kesa when I see it.
I think so too, yeah.
He's in so many games actually, like so many people put him
in stuff.
Yeah, I mean he's one of the biggest streamers out there
right now.
I mean it's like free publicity because like he plays your
games and stuff too.
Yeah, yeah.
You can worry about where you'll report once you get that
rhinoplasty.
Oh my god!
Whoa, Kesa!
Who's pushing me?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Yes.
No, my TV!
No more TV for you little girl.
You would have never been able to work here if it wasn't for
her.
We're gonna be fighting.
They're fighting the drama.
How dare you?
I'm a certified news anchor.
Certified.
Yeah, my ass.
Who's the other guy?
I don't know.
This could be us.
That could be us.
That could be literally be us right now.
I'm on the left and you're on the right.
Yeah.
Because I'm a certified news anchor.
Are you exhausted?
Since when?
Yeah.
Is your 9 to 5 stressing you out?
Is that vacation with rentacabin.com?
Oh my god, we used that!
That's what we did!
That's what we- Oh wait, that's the place that we- That's
the zip house!
That's the zip house!
In our refurbished cabins.
Now, not only are these cabins cheap, but they're also- I'm
concerned that they didn't put the cabin that we rented on
the commercial.
I do not trust Jimmy.
I don't...
They should have had a body double.
Including pet friendly, alcohol friendly, family sized,
underground.
Underground?
Get the bunker?
Get the red decaven bunker for the end of the world?
Yeah.
Rent a bunker?
What's this?
You can beat me, but you can never beat the taste of UFO
burgers.
UFO burgers.
Oh, I want a burger.
I'm going to get a burger tonight.
I want to get a burger tonight, too.
Yeah.
From the Burr O2 galaxy to the Gurr O4 galaxy.
Our journey begins with the best beef source in the most
unconventional way.
In what way?
Oh.
Wait, man, when's Batara's concert again?
Oh, seven.
Okay, we got to finish this before I start.
We got to get it.
Oh, shoot.
We even started early.
We were too busy watching TV and writing a very real story.
All right, we'll stop watching TV.
Wait, no, wait, wait.
But what's this important into the game?
Oh, my God.
I will have to leave.
You'll have to finish the game by yourself.
No, no, no.
This is, we just got, we'll just do it next week.
We'll finish it next.
This inspired Cloud Clicker.
It said the game is like two hours long.
What's this?
Look, the devs put a lot of effort into these commercials.
We got appreciate all the little details that they did for
us.
I will exit this collab and I will go fulfill my duties this
is part of fulfilling your duties that this was on your
schedule I didn't make a schedule this week well that's on
you professional streamer okay well you know I said I was
gonna be on your channel and here I am I'm fulfilling this
duty and I can whatever you can't hold me hostage oh what's
this what's this one yeah what's this one gmod oh hey
welcome back there are you gonna oh okay maybe he's taking
their order you know that's true to lighten the atmosphere
here in the last report i mentioned oh he's playing fears of
phantom okay if you want well this morning scoffy that's
counted as one of those moments and no we're not analyze you
for that of course but it's mainly for you that i'm doing
this i mean look at tina oh i hear the eating noises oh yeah
yeah it's really common in these games you're getting pushed
again what is he trying to do he's trying to get you to stop
watching tv and play the game um fourth wall breaking that's
not very immersive dead it's over this company what i'm
gonna blow Up, up, boom.
Fuck you, Chad.
What did Chadden do?
I print in silence.
Was that a printer ad?
Is that printer ad?
And C-Sonic.
Oh my god.
By our printers.
This guy definitely did not kill himself.
She suicide.
In Minecraft.
You put it up Minecraft and then jumped off a clip.
This one's cool.
I think it's like a music video.
This one looks normal.
Oh, it is.
Yeah.
Latest album.
Neck care, black up.
Sounds pretty good.
Mind melting music.
You should listen.
Did this guy put on a soundcloud?
Yeah.
Brain rot.
Actual customer.
It was all right.
It's pretty all right.
Deadlighter.
How many?
Oh my gosh.
There's so many ads.
When will we get back to the news channel?
Right.
I'm bored.
Is this a music video?
seven hours of ads
was that world cup I'm gonna go get a snack wait wait you
can't skip on this ad the dev worked really hard on this
you're the one watching it at least somebody is watching it
yeah but we could be watching it together what if he's like
testing us right now what if the devs watching this vibe to
be like are they actual fans of years to fathom and then you
leave in the middle of this work and he was like oh yeah
jokie bird's dedicated but what about mint phantome he would
know how to say my name right what about mint phantome
I have a dog this doesn't even apply to me yeah but you
could buy a dog buy a car for that dog and then purchase
some of the high-end insurance That is made for you because
you don't have any of this.
I have nothing!
Only $299.99 a year.
We offer dirt cheap coverage for quality vehicles.
You'll never find better prices anywhere.
Especially not at our competitor.
God, that would you get it.
Because we're the best.
Hmm.
I don't know.
Inbreed Diamond Great House.
We inbreed?
That's cool.
That they're inbreed?
No, well, not the...
No, the weapon, I mean, I guess.
Oh.
Desperately need a break.
We saw this one.
All right, there we go.
Now we can go.
Take a vacation.
Yay!
We're free!
Oh, a mountain pew.
Where's my mountain pew?
Oh.
Yay!
Wait, what is that?
It's mountain pew.
I had to open this.
This guy's trying to talk to you.
He's trying to talk to you.
I don't think he was.
No, he has a lot of things to say.
Oh, there you go.
How you doing, my friend?
I'm pretty hungry.
Piece of dust, though.
Awfully good.
Are you here for the pizza?
No, just looking for a little help.
Maybe I can help you.
Yeah.
Maybe you can, but you go and get some pizza first, eh?
Oh, he's Canadian.
Maybe we'll catch up later.
Oh my god, he needs help killing someone.
He's the killer.
Where did you...
I feel like Mike is more of a killer than this random
Canadian.
Oh, just because he's Canadian, he's a killer?
Yeah.
That's fucked, bro.
There's Mike.
I talked to these guys.
How's your day going?
Who are you?
you i'm cindy i'm cindy look cindy we're just here to enjoy
our pizza in pairs thanks for understanding uh i hope you
enjoy your meal come and see for yourself burgers so
delicious all right let's get our burgers oh wait oh yeah
see ya evening folks oh yeah no you can you could be him oh
yeah evening folks looks like gold's got everyone craving
pizza tonight yeah I can't leave.
No, I want the bird.
Oh, okay.
There you go.
It's fine.
You fine.
Folks, you know what you want to eat?
Like, where do I click?
Click on him.
I am.
Where do I click?
Oh, oh, it's here.
Does Tanya?
Dot, dot, dot.
All right, Mike.
Oh.
Oh, that'll be a lot.
Well, we'll get three slices each.
I'll go with pepperoni, cheese, and a veggie.
Oh, and for you, Miss, I'll get the most special.
What's your say?
And the most special.
Any drinks for you, folks?
Oh, my God.
And she can't see it.
It's so small.
that should cover us just the pizza today thanks we're
getting three slices of pizza and no no drinks like that's
so oily all right then six hot slices coming right up
that'll be 22.50 don't pay don't pay i'm not paying oh of
course you did mike oh snap i left my wallet in the car.
Do you have cash, Harper?
Oh my god, I can't even say anything else.
I have to pay.
This guy's a deadbeat.
This is so typical Mike.
Mike behavior.
I know.
He's such a Mike, bro.
He also decided for us.
He was just like, I'm gonna get three slices.
Yeah, I'm like, I'm gonna get pizza.
Oh, wow.
I conveniently left it.
Left my wallet in the car.
Even though I wanted to get pizza.
Yeah.
Oh, it's not like I parked literally right outside the door.
Yeah, it's not like I could go out and grab my wallet right
now.
Yeah.
Be like, oh, just one second.
Let me go grab it.
Yeah.
Your order number is 27.
Just grab a seat and we'll call you up when your pizza's
ready.
All right.
Well, this is the only seat.
Where did my mountain pew go?
Did Mike just take your seat?
Mike, that was my seat.
I said this is my seat.
a few oh wait i see it by the trash can by the trash can go
turn around turn around there you see the trash can yeah oh
there it is i'm trying to open it how do i oh i had to
scroll it says there's literal literal instructions i can
read order 27 wait most special is even 20 off you You made
me pay full price for pizza.
Oh my god.
And I'm paying for it too, Mike.
This guy, the audacity.
The audacity to be like.
Yeah, the pizzas are like, you know, like all the meals are
on me and he orders steak and champagne.
Do you have any recommendations?
Get the cheese.
Okay.
Oh no.
Just all.
Uh oh.
Wait, we messed up.
We messed up.
We did not get the cheese.
We did.
just the cheese.
The cheese, only the cheese.
Wait for that guy to come out.
You probably sneak back in there and get the cheese.
Oh, that's true.
I was going to do that.
Yeah.
Maybe I can talk to him.
Oh, not yet.
Maybe this is the moment where I should have been watching
TV.
Probably.
Or you could talk.
There's other people, those people there too.
Oh, yeah, it's true.
Maybe it's one of those things you have to talk to
everybody.
How's the pizza?
It's great, actually.
I think most might have ruined other pizzas for us.
It's the good?
Oh, are you from here?
Oh no, we're on a way to a conference in the next town over.
Not too much further to go.
You and me that guy.
We just stopped to eat whenever a place looks interesting.
This place definitely has a cozy vibe.
Best decision of the trip so far.
just passing through.
We're heading to a rental in Woodbury.
Woodbury, huh?
We passed aside for that.
Didn't we, Chris?
Oh, you're Chris now.
I'm Chris.
Oh, you don't care.
I better get back to this pizza.
Have a safe trip and be careful of the snow.
Enjoy the pizza.
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
How's the pizza?
Well, my dear, you absolutely can't go wrong with the pepper
and only here at most.
He's about to dismiss Latvia.
Well, my dear.
It's the first time a woman has talked to him in 20 years,
okay?
Okay, I can make it up.
Everybody reminds you of a story.
You got to do this by the pizza.
so what brings you to most uh we're heading to a cabin in
woodbury yeah woodbury you say a beautiful place used to
camp there quite often when i was a younger man there's
something about being out in the wilderness nothing but the
stars overhead those memories just stay with you.
Okay, Grandpa.
Anyway, I'm rambling.
Young lady, you made a wonderful choice stopping here at
Modes.
Do you come here often?
Oh, my dear.
Ah, yeah, I'm like, am I trying to pick up this Grandpa?
Nora's not here, so he could be the third.
Oh, My dear, I've been coming to Moe since 85.
This place is full of memories for me.
Wow.
Though my daughter bless her.
She tries to keep me from eating too much pizza.
Bad for a man my age, she says.
She worries too much.
Only have one of these heavenly slices about twice a month
now.
Well, it was nice chatting with you.
Safe travels to you and your friend.
It's nice knowing you, Grandpa.
Oh, nice.
I talked to all the NPCs in the pizzeria.
Look, this is our audition tape right now to the devs.
Okay, we gotta put our whole spirit and energy into this.
This is my pizza.
Where the fuck is my pizza?
right here please have a seat oh my god can't wait can't
wait i can't wait i want my pizza now pizza they told me to
like wait just wait i guess be patient i'm like how long not
to wait for me want pizza he's not even making it he's just
i know is that our pizza
I mean, I feel like this guy's first He should have had his
pizza already, but he hasn't He hasn't Talk to Mike, what
does he gotta say?
Long sniff Oh, I thought he was just clearing his nose Yeah
All right It smells so good in here Long sniff
That's it I'm getting out of Oh, oh, never mind Oh.
All right.
Oh, my God.
No, please.
You have so many.
Wait, there's so many texts.
Oh, my.
Do you guys hear about Taylor?
Oh, my God.
What about Taylor and Baxter?
Wait.
All right.
Please be careful.
Oh, yeah.
Because she has to drive through the snow too.
Wait, did Mike say I'll make sure that we are up to let her
in?
Why don't you stay up, Mike?
Wait.
Yeah.
Wait a minute.
That's not cool, Mike.
Oh, I can read Ricky's message now.
Wait, that's Lily Pichu?
Wait, this is Lily Pichu?
This could be us.
They got Lily.
They could get us.
Oh, my God, it is!
Is it really?
Yeah, that is her!
Oh.
Wait, there's more.
More of Lily.
Yeah, that's her.
That's her.
Here's the thing right now.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's a good totally BS.
We could do it.
We can do it easy.
Yeah, we could do this.
We can definitely do this.
Yeah, I feel like we could do we could be voice actors in
their next game.
Open a Patreon.
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Open Patreon.
We will be the next voice actor.
One way or another.
why it sounds like we're in Italy it's so funny yeah oh my
god there's so many texts did you hear about Taylor and
Baxter Baxter got pregnant and now they're planning a Star
Wars themed baby shower I can just see it now a birth
announcement that says the force is strong with this one oh
geez Mikey did they tie to not tell me they didn't get
married wait Mikey dot dot dot lol oh oh this is a group
chat friends forever I was like of them yeah you're the
biggest nerd i know other than backstory we totally get this
is so cute all you need is love the beetles oh it's not star
wars i thought they were what she didn't get the invite oh
she was like remember don't tell them they got married
because i didn't get the invite oh my god that's so awkward
that's so awkward though i'm gonna give like this
been invited yeah wow it looked like they had so much fun
together i'm gonna tell me how they met beo's tribute
concert in high school it's so stinking cute that schools
our call of friends are moving out with their lives and
getting married and i'm here busting my ass and revising
designs for a company i don't even care about but seriously
i feel you go may as well put a bed in my office because it
feels like i live here we're practically zombies at this
point mike surprise pikachu yeah mike what did you do Mike
what do you Mike contributing nothing to the conversation
you just ladies ladies why don't we go to a cabin just the
three of us oh I'm the only guy here I don't I rent a house
it'll be like a college days we watch movie eat junk food
whatever we want maybe we get high I'm sure one of my old
content could come through.
Oh yeah, that's when it wasn't legal.
Yeah, I was like, what do you mean old contacts?
That actually sounds like a great idea.
Our own cozy little getaway for the weekend.
I love it.
I getaway.
I don't know, Mike.
Sounds like a lot of work.
Plus, I'm swamped right now.
My boss just dropped two new clients on me this week.
Yeah.
One was apex.
What are you doing, Mike?
You seem to have so much free time on your hands.
Yeah, Mike.
Think about it hard.
Can't even fucking pizza, Mike.
A week away from all the stress.
No work, no deadlines.
It'll be like girl's trip, but with Mike.
Maybe we should just do a girl's trip.
Yeah, I'm just like I feel like Nora's trying to imply
something.
Right.
You see it?
Did you know that, uh, what was it called?
Uh, until dawn too is coming out?
Yeah!
I can't wait to play it.
Oh my gosh, me too.
You say like it's a bad thing.
I don't know, guys.
I'll get back with you after I think it over.
This reminds me of Until Dawn for some reason.
Oh, just the conversation because it's a bad.
XO, XO, Mike will die first.
Mike will die but we'll make sure of it.
We'll make sure.
Honestly, the more I think about it, the more I like the
idea.
That's the spirit.
Heartbeat, let's make it happen.
All right, I'm in, but there better be wine involved.
All right, good deal.
I'll bring some pizza supplies.
Not the kind of wake and bake Mike has in mind, but it'll be
so good.
that's where we stopped there okay well we get to oh my god
there's so many wait i didn't read what oh we have
individuals hex too oh they're so tired i was just about
tuning in for what about you all right your turn that much
just keeping things afloat my friend how's the work at the
new firm pretty much the same as the old job just coding my
life away he's also a engineer that's he was so jealous he
works he works at microsoft no he works at google oh he
works at google yeah that's why he was so jealous of us when
we talked to gail yeah from the eighth floor yeah there's
like a rivalry yeah but then he does have money what the
fuck bro yeah oh mike like i really don't know he always
sounds fun but it'll be so much work to get weekend all i'm
gonna do is sing about all the work i should be getting done
at the office listen to yourself harp we're talking about a
nice relaxing weekend getaway and all you are focusing on is
how to make is how to make relaxing i like how to like my
messages when mike is so professional and then i see nora
i'm like you you me and taylor i know right i'm so excited
but Are you going to drive alone?
I'm so glad I have.
Thanks, girl.
Smiley faces and everything.
And I'm like, I haven't had a real break in a long time.
I haven't had a real break in ages, Mike.
I'm not even sure I remember how to relax anymore.
I work all day.
And when I get home, all I think about is the work.
I don't get finished.
It's hard to just unplug, you know?
That's exactly why you should come.
Think of it this way, Sydney Harper.
You're like a battery full of power and productivity.
Happens when you run the battery too long.
It loses, it loses, it's charge.
We've got to put you back on the charger harp.
You'll go back to work after that weekend with more energy
than ever.
20% more productivity, I bet.
Come on.
Who knows?
Maybe you'll think of me later.
Like that face.
Not that face.
Yes, that face.
Oh yeah, and also Nora, by the way.
Remember Nora?
Oh yeah, Nora's so excited.
Yeah, by the way.
You should text him right here and see if he responds.
I can't.
The game won't let me press enter.
I was like, sorry, I passed out last night.
He sends a pair.
It's like, oh, I'm sorry.
I passed out last night.
Damn it.
Fine.
Check in with H.R.
and let you know.
Oh, he sent a heart emoji too.
whoa whoa it's getting serious oh he's like so concerned
he's like just booked do you answer the phone call me please
i'm off work now we're at work oh my god oh my god but you
see who i'm text back though i text back sorry mike is our
pizza ready what i don't know i've just been
getting up I'm how do you get up I'm oh oh did you listen to
you listen to Nora's voice message in the group yeah I just
saw looks like she'll be late that's a bummer I guess we'll
have to start the fun without her what can we do don't act
like you don't know what I'm talking about what are we
talking about yeah what gonna do oh why did he leave it at
that yeah oh the order number twice okay thank god all right
oh thank god i'm gonna get up what do you mike what does he
mean what does he mean i'm scared i'm scared time to eat
your pizza all right you folks are all set thank you yeah
say thanks Oh, there's the most special.
How about those eating sounds?
This pizza slaps.
Can't believe Nora is missing out on this bomb-ass pizza.
I know, right?
That's how I eat my pizza, too.
Yeah, that's exactly how it sounds.
If you sat next to Doki Bird, you would hear this consuming
consuming damn harp you actually eat the crust what's wrong
with the crust yeah the crust is fine especially we have dip
sauce for it yeah yeah or feed it to dad yeah i feel it to
him all right crust time it's gonna get too fat it's gotta
wasteful not to don't you I guess but you want to eat really
eat the peel of an orange would you that's not the same
thing that's not the same that's not the same thing just
exit the conversation I just say yeah don't even the most
special um um um um um hey there my friends hello there I
saw that you you y'all pulling driving a nice little truck
Are you just, okay, are you just watching who pulls in
taking notes?
Not at all.
We were so nice to him before, right?
Yeah, but then, I don't know.
Mike said something off on me.
I'm shooting it out ever yet.
It's the eating sound.
I'm going to start shooting now.
Not at all, my friend.
I just noticed him to be heading the same direction.
Oh, is he a hitchhiker?
Y'all mind that hitch a ride with you?
Where's your car?
Who needs a car when there are five friends like you don't
pass the time with?
Oh, oh, friends, you mean people you could leech off of?
Oh, yeah.
Y'all wouldn't even know I was there.
Quiet as a church.
That's even worse, I feel like, if your hitchhiker doesn't
even talk.
He's just sitting there.
Quiet as a church, mice, and twice as nice.
So what do you say?
Can't give this free spirit a ride down that snowy road.
like we're last choice he was talking to everybody yeah wait
can i say no what happened can i just say sure just let him
come yeah yeah let's hold on to so hold on a second don't
you think we need to discuss this isn't that what we're
doing i'm not sure if we have an extra space for another
passenger oh i'm sorry i didn't think of that So if he if he
is a murderer, he'll murder him first because I was being
yeah, he will we were nice to him We were nice to him.
He'll murder him first.
Yeah.
Surely you can find just a little bit of room for me I can
ride in the middle hell.
I'll ride in the bat bed in the bed That's not that's not
allowed.
That's a big.
It's my friend's car.
I'm sorry You gotta be oh Oh no
wasn't the one that said no why did he start say fuck me for
say no you're so getting murdered i'm still getting murdered
i'm getting murdered you're gonna skip mike too you ain't
too kind are you unkind people me unkindness themselves you
bet me what do you me mike over there whistling he's like
he's not even saying anything he's not even intervening Now
you talk!
Are you threatening us?
The eating sounds are...
No, no.
You got me all...
Y'all got me all wrong.
Sorry, I'm just cold and tired is all.
Didn't he call us a bitch?
Yeah, he just called me a bitch!
It said I was gonna get killed!
Yeah!
I'm gonna eat my pizza.
Stress eating over here.
Yeah, I got stressy real quick.
The guy just threatened me.
Are you serious?
How are you gonna let a stranger ride with us in the middle
of nowhere?
That guy was gonna murder us if I didn't.
Yeah, you seem to- he seemed heartless, honestly.
I don't know.
Seems like a nice old guy.
He does, doesn't he?
We never really know these days.
For all we know, he could have been another Ted Bundy.
Yeah.
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, just like ASMR eating sounds too.
It's not even like regular eating sound effects.
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
Me done.
Oh, burp.
Oh.
Did he burp back at you?
Yes.
We both looked at each other, too.
Just in silence.
all right oh oh i can't i thought it would like give me some
random prop he's a great great contribution to the
conversation nora
oh that guy's blocked in let him go holy that was good all
right then are you ready to hit the road maybe we can beat
the worst of the All right, give me, oh, I'll drive.
Yeah, yeah, you drive, Disha.
Oh, he doesn't like that.
Harp, the weather is awful.
Why don't you drive part of the way home?
Oh, take a break while I drive, Michael.
Oh, we're full name right now.
I'm afraid of what kind of break you're going to give me,
Harp.
Well, you'll be afraid you'll give me the keys.
Fine, but there's one condition.
what is it he's gonna ask to hold your hand oh I get first
choice of bedroom's win or if we get there dear we booked a
place man come on yeah I paid for the whole place come on
bro and I paid for pizza where is the hitchhiker didn't he
left right he did leave yeah he's also like he's in the bed
of the car yeah I was going to say, maybe I should check the
back of the car.
I was going to say, could he threaten the other people in
the pizzeria?
Because he asked the other people.
And then he was like, oh, there's something that happened to
you.
Yeah, yeah, people should complain about him and get him
kicked out.
Yeah, maybe that's why he left.
You got kicked out.
Oh, maybe.
He was like, hey, hey, three strikes, you're out.
Yeah, quit bothering my customers and threatening them with
violence.
It was 549?
Oh, yeah, we...
for about an hour, I guess.
Felt way longer.
Didn't it, guys?
Get up.
Oh.
Are we here?
It's a very cold night.
I think.
What do you think?
I think the address was 241 Woodbury Boulevard.
Oh, is this not the right place?
Isn't that?
No, I think you got to go a little further down.
All right, give me a sec.
All right.
All right, here we go.
Ooh, this is a nice song.
Bada, bada.
Whose SoundCloud is this?
Yeah.
We should have our song in the game.
Harp, did you get your license from a cereal box?
I just wanted to know if I'll go into the ocean.
or the lake the pond i want to know if they dokey proofed my
driving they definitely did not they did not no they did
because i can't drive myself into the water oh which one is
our cabin 240 what one was it 240.
is it the ones behind us it's probably lit up right oh oh i
don't know
Okay, it's a really narrow road, guys.
Please understand.
Yeah, please understand.
This road is very narrow.
Like, it could happen to anybody.
There were cabins behind us, but I didn't know that those
were the...
What does that say?
Oh.
Well, I need to see where is that said.
Okay, in three miles.
Alright.
Three miles.
Just keep on going.
We have to go right side.
Look, it says I was out of practice.
that should be a wood bear that makes sense yeah yeah yeah
it's been a while guys this is this could happen to anybody
exactly i think you're i'm offside doing on purpose that
wouldn't be yeah there's no way that has to be ours right oh
i think that's a church no no it's i'm fine i'm fine i'm
fine i just went i thought that was the drive i no no i got
you took out the skin of that house.
It's now just blanks.
I thought that was where that was my house.
No, that was obviously the church from the game we just
played.
We'll go back then.
It's like, welcome back.
Wait, is that it?
Oh, I think this is it.
Is that it?
Yeah, I think so.
No, is it?
No, if it was, I'd be able to say.
What's the number say?
Wait, there's numbers on it?
I don't know.
Isn't it 241?
It was just like he's turned off but it's good music it
sounds so sad yeah this is definitely it no oh let me check
is that it to there's no no no i don't think so just yeah no
it's not yeah it's not what oh i so creepy oh my god whoa
whoa oh i did not like that the killer the killer I did not
like that.
That gave me killer violence.
That was like a poor shout.
He might kill us if we don't go to the right place.
Maybe I drive past it.
He'll tell me.
I don't think it's that because there's a car in front of
it.
I don't remember.
Yeah, I don't think so either.
I don't remember what it looked like in the listing.
Me too.
I don't remember either.
You would tell us if we missed it.
as bad as him like eyes on the road dokey come on i'm trying
to find the cows mike's not helping there's a gas station
jesus sets you free oh shackled by lust do you think it's
this way or the other way it said this is woodbury okay
where are the numbers let's see woodbury oh yeah we're in
woodbury okay where the fuck are the numbers on the houses
how am i supposed to know okay there's cars in front of that
one wait there's numbers on the mailbox.
Wait, 240.
Wait, wait, wait.
240.
Wait, that's it.
That's it.
240.
1, 340.
We got it.
There we go.
First try.
Wait, why is it?
Oh, what's coming up?
I think the ad... I'm right there!
That's where we are!
Oh, I don't like that.
There's a gap.
Wait, was it?
Was it...
Oh, I could have parked.
I could have parked this.
I mean, that's technically parked.
Do you think that, wait, the owner is like in the basement
or something?
Maybe it's the owners, yeah.
Yeah.
Well, someone has to let you in, right?
Here we are.
I crashed my truck.
My legs fell asleep.
One second.
All right.
That's as parked as I could get.
Yeah, I think so, too.
Oh.
He's gone.
It's a quaint little house.
It's a quiet little neighborhood.
Oh, hold to slide.
Yep.
I don't fucking...
Did he send me the code?
He probably did.
Oh, he did.
There it is.
Five.
Oh, that means there's someone in here.
That there is someone in here.
Six?
Wasn't it seven six?
Was it?
oh oh my gosh she's dyslexic too you guys aren't you going
to get your bag dot dot dot yeah just dot dot him that fuck
is my bag don't we need the keys first buddy before we yeah
before we do anything else come on buddy how are you getting
the house god so there's someone else here someone's gonna
jump scare you he's gonna be like oh it's me the owner.
I'm the owner.
What a great place.
I knew we could count on you.
It smells so nice in here.
Right, but I really need to hit the John.
Alright, take your time, Mike.
Well, I'm gone.
Can you put these groceries away?
Should be enough space in the fridge.
Sure.
How long have we been driving with these groceries?
Where is the groceries?
Where did he...
Oh, he put it right here.
Um, why did you not put this in the goddamn kitchen?
Because he hates you.
My god, I bet you I paid for all the food too.
What's in there?
What did he bring?
Oh my god, come on.
Can we trust him to bring something delicious?
What did he bring?
He brought...
What the fuck is that?
Bananas?
Alright, you got best milk.
Best milk.
Oh, the best.
The best of the best, baby.
Oh my god, please.
Just put it in the... No, don't put it.
Stop touching the door!
He got his eggs, he got his yogurt, he got his bell peppers,
lettuce.
What is he making with this?
He got tomatoes.
It's just eggs.
Is that our only protein, Mike?
I think so.
Gotta have two cartons of milk, though.
Yeah, gotta have two cartons of milk.
Sorry about that, Harp.
Are you okay?
You were in the bathroom for way too long.
and all that pizza really did a number on me well all the
groceries are put away thanks for handling i should say i
need a p2 yeah this place looks crazy nice it's got that
rustic charm that just you don't see anymore uh it's nice to
oh wait hang on i really need to really need to pay yeah you
can go ahead i'll start unpacking our bags all right dot dot
dot dot dot yeah don't even give him the satisfaction why
are you not oh i can't even Turn on the lights.
Can I pee with the door open?
Oh, couldn't do it with the door wide open.
Our pee meter is back.
Alright, we're peeing.
We're speed running.
My speed tech.
We can text on the toilet.
We're gonna get hemorrhoids doing that.
Hi, I checked in.
Oh, okay, I texted him.
Oh, yeah.
You did.
You said hi.
We checked in.
Yep.
You're in the bathroom toilet too long.
You'll get hemorrhoids, guys.
Don't play on Don't do gotcha on your phone.
No, don't crouch.
Oh, because of it.
There's other cars.
Oh, there's a taxi.
Where is Nora?
She's leaving us alone.
Hate to admit, but I didn't wash my hands after being.
Don't be burnt.
Does not wash your hands after being.
I got distracted.
I was concerned.
I was like, what is Nora?
She admits it.
She hates to admit it, but she admitted it.
much uh which i'm good want to check out the house
sounds good to me let's see what this place has to offer all
right after you dot dot dot all right i can oh look see see
i washed my hands oh yeah let me high five mike real quick
only after you got publicly shamed for it no it's because i
wanted to i want to high five mike and then and then hands.
Oh, uh, we go upstairs.
Okay.
We saw the guy upstairs here.
Yeah, he's probably just around the corner.
He's just there.
He's gonna be like, he's right there.
He's under the bed.
He's right here.
Might be here.
He might be here.
Oh, he's there.
Oh, he's behind us.
He's in the cupboard.
Uh, I called dips on this one.
All yours.
Okay, buddy.
All right, buddy.
Sure.
room that oh hey you're here who are you welcome to my home
sweet home what a lovely young couple no no we're not a
couple we're not a couple that that would hurt mikey no no
no not a couple there's like
The three nose.
We didn't have to sell it that hard, heart.
Well, I was just answering his question.
It wasn't a question.
He didn't ask a question.
He made a statement and you...
Never mind.
No, no, no, no!
No!
Oopsie daisy.
Hi, silly me.
You didn't mean to cause us to ruin you too.
We didn't expect anyone to be here.
here oh um i was out looking for my cat earlier i remember
tv has been on the fritz here just thought i'd stop by and
try to get it working again since the last few folks left a
bad word for it you know they say treat your guests like
family my family doesn't go about tv oh dokeybird would
perish if she did not know i didn't have my tv on and
watched the 20 minutes of ads yeah speaking of that around
my sweet home right now maybe a bad owner i didn't give you
the grand tour all right let me oh whoa whoa whoa oh geez no
this was a middle-aged man with are you coming miss what i'm
trying hey let me turn off the tv i know right this presence
made us uncomfortable here's your shower that thing make you
feel like you're bathing under a waterfall in the amazon
jungle This sink doesn't work, unfortunately.
Not to worry.
I'll get it fixed for you real soon.
Let me show you the other bedroom now.
All right, let's see.
He kind of looks like the guy from Smiling Friends.
Oh, yeah, he does.
Oh, the boss, right?
Yeah, yeah.
McCarp, this room has a nice ass view.
How would you know?
It has a nice ass view.
You think that's nice, mister?
Wait till I show you the deck.
Follow me now, please.
dot dot dot how would he know oh can oh okay what kind of
view is that that's not a nice view sure got the laundry
room oh that's where you do the laundry oh oh oh you're so
close to him all right so you're gonna talk about holy
smokes this is incredible incredibly cold glad your folks
like it this is one of my favorite spots the view of the
creek is beautiful it's a great spot for fishing too alright
folks let's head back in before I catch the cold here again
where's the creek
there is one because you can fish in this game I don't see
anything it's like back there yeah they're like this is a
great view and I was like Suburbia?
View of the creek questionable.
Here's the storage room.
If you need anything, tools, extra blankets, well not, it's
all in here.
If the power ever goes out, you can use this flashlight.
Oh, we're shadowing.
We're going to be using a flashlight for sure.
Storm's like, you never know.
Thanks.
Alright, folks, let's head downstairs now.
Alright, I'm ready.
It's not that big of a house.
I think we would have been out there.
to figure this out.
Yeah, I think so, too.
It was, like, four rooms.
Right?
Is he gonna introduce me to the kitchen now that I
already... Yep.
Oh, okay.
We've already made ourselves... Oh, oh, he's gonna... Oh!
He already stocked up the fridge with some tasty food.
Yep.
Uh, my two...
My two bottles of milk and eggs.
Yeah.
You see the knob?
And bell peppers.
Turn the knob up for more cooling and then down to cool it
off.
I didn't keep it low in the... Oh, wait.
I didn't keep it low in the winter.
The bill gets out of control.
Speaking of wonder, I better show you folks the water here.
Oh, that's important.
Yeah.
Yeah, that would be.
That would be pretty important.
Yeah, we got... Oh, oh.
You have lights for the basement?
I do not like that.
Alright, thank you guys.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, is he right?
His little workshop.
Yeah.
Nothing to worry about, Dan.
Just the water here and some old story stuff.
If every stops working, you hit the buttons at the bottom.
The potlight will fire right up and you'll be back in
business.
Okay, so this.
I remember to hit that.
Yeah, I remember to hit that.
I am coming over.
Why is it just so close?
That's you.
Oh, hey, sir.
What's the deal with that room over there?
Nothing you two need to concern yourself with.
I kind of use this basement as storage.
Renters don't need the space.
They really ought to keep up to say, oh, we're not allowed
downstairs.
Okay, well, I was just curious.
We're not allowed downstairs.
Let's keep going.
No access to yes.
Oh, that, I didn't, no, I didn't do anything.
I saw you trying.
He's pissed.
He's going to kill you.
I didn't touch nothing Did I mention Well, no Maybe I ought
to keep it to myself That fella bought The fella bought this
house from Well, told me his mother Died Oh Was she 60 plus
Was she living in the walls Was she living in the walls The
walls of the basement Oh, no this is a murder house some
guests have reported hearing voices did she start moving in
the walls said they could hear something shuffling down here
not to scare you folks but if I were one of you I wouldn't
really step down here oh god
okay looks on your faces
come on now I'm just joking no wonder it was $99 at this
point my creepy meter was quality pinging around a 6 out of
10 that's a 6 that's a 6 right yeah Alrighty folks, snow is
starting to pick up.
I'm going to hit the road now.
Gotta find that damn cat.
Thanks for showing us around.
I feel like he could sell it or like, you know, like
advertise it as a haunted house.
Yeah, like people would be like...
Yeah, you could get like Ghostbusters in here.
Yeah.
Like, look at those YouTubers.
YouTubers love touring these houses with a little recording
thing where they'd be like, tell us what are you?
And they'd be like, boop, boop, boop.
Yes!
I am here I'm waiting for them to come to my cafe Oh, it's
the name on the booking I miss be getting old It's Sydney
Doesn't know your name Sydney, that's right Pretty name for
a pretty girl Dot dot dot A microaggression Get out of here
Is that me or is that dude super weird Oh, when Mike thinks
someone's weird Then Yeah That's really weird.
Yeah, that's not a good sign.
Very weird.
Actually, let's see if there's anything good on...
No, no more tea.
No!
Oh, I'm going to take a shower.
You're going to...
Cool, I'll find something to watch while you're in there.
Okay, good.
Let me know if it feels like you're under a waterfall in the
Amazon.
Yeah.
What a weird guy.
Thanks.
See you in a bit.
All right.
Guess I'll go take a shower now.
Alright, let's see if I feel like I'm in the Amazon, guys.
Oh.
I didn't even take any of my clothes.
Hey, nope.
Just, they dissolve off of you.
Yeah, yeah, I have dissolvable clothes.
Yeah.
Not very economical, but like, hey, no laundry, you know?
Yeah, exactly.
Don't have to do laundry.
Just clogging up the pipes with your dissolvable clothes.
Did it feel like the Amazon?
It felt like the Amazon.
He was right.
The reviews were right.
Wow, TV's off.
What happened?
Whoa!
Oh, he went fishing.
Hey, Harp.
Check this out.
I found this fishing rod in that shed.
Planning catch dinner?
Now that you've mentioned, that would be pretty epic
addition.
A pretty epic addition to the trip.
Let's fucking do it.
Let's fucking go.
Hell yeah.
Follow me.
There's another rod in the shed.
So we can both give it a shot.
Oh yeah, the two.
I forgot this house had two reviews.
Wait, was this the one with two?
Oh yeah, this was the two review house.
The reviews were right.
The TV wasn't working, but it felt like I was under the
Amazon.
That was only one review that like said that, and then they
just ran with it.
They tell everybody now.
Yeah, like, as in all the reviews That's said in my house
had the Amazon-like showers.
Amazon, yeah.
Do you want to grab the other fishing rod, Harp?
Yeah, just give me a second.
Where is the other fishing rod?
Where?
Oh, I think it's below.
Oh, it's that's the ice here.
There you go.
Grab some bait.
Oh, snap.
I saw a killer recipe for baked carp.
His thing is, why does he look like that?
Yeah, is he okay?
He'll need to catch a great carp, though.
This looks like we're in the back rooms.
It does.
All right, three carp.
First things first, we need the right bait for carp.
Check out this bait information board.
Whatever you're ready, grab a carp bait and let's head to
the creek.
We're going to catch some carp harp.
Let me, please don't make rhymes with mine.
All right, no comment.
Carp bait.
Which one is carp?
catching it's over here chub oh common car there's a car
cheese delight cheese delight they have good taste oh there
is cheese oh sweet corn too oh let's get they have a car
there he goes there i'm ready i have to get three carp
that's right okay oh oh we got a lawn chair too for fishing
Yeah!
Now we're fishing.
Okay, that was my seat.
What the fuck?
Mike is such a bastard.
Okay.
Put it on hook.
Did I not put it on hook?
Is it not?
My thing isn't on it.
Wait, what do you mean?
Which, what thing is not on it?
I want to put the bait.
Is it on it?
I can't tell.
Oh, it is.
It is.
Wait, is it?
No, it's not.
No, right mouse button.
Okay, I can cast it.
Yeah, just cast it.
I'm casting it.
Yeah, whatever.
Fuck it.
It's in your biting.
Oh.
Nice.
Oh, you're so close.
Oh.
You're so close.
There.
Oh, my God.
What is happening?
Oh, there we go.
I did it.
Yeah.
Oh.
I'll keep it.
That's a great oh That's a great fish harp, but we're on a
carp catching mission today toss that one back in Yeah, a
fish a fish.
Yeah Oh and the right corner says okay.
I get it.
Yeah, okay your bait All right Oh, he's slow Oh nice.
Oh, oh again.
It's Same guy.
It is.
He says, please take me with you.
Please.
This was my dream.
I don't want to live in this water no more.
Is that what happens if like, this just don't want to be
alive anymore to just get caught?
Probably.
Oh my god.
It's still this guy.
Next one is the one.
Next one.
Yeah.
He's going to have too many holes in him.
from it's like he found the yeah he found the infinite money
glitch he's just like more cheese yeah what if he's a stream
sniper that'd be so funny
oh my god go get a different bait i mean wait wait one more
one more it said common carp
jeez i swear to god if it's him again i swear to god i'm
getting something else okay oh my i'm i'm grabbing another
pig yeah go grab yeah i'm grabbing another one can you run
in this game no i'm just leisurely walking oh okay we got
we're so chill we got nowhere to be we're so chill yeah yeah
we're just here to fish and yeah all right i'm gonna get the
corn it says Carmen, Carmen, carp right there.
Where the fuck is the corn?
That's the golden lord.
Oh, there it is.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, I can't.
I can't drop it.
G?
Oh, I can.
There you go.
Yeah, there you go.
Alright, we'll get the corn.
Corn is so much better.
Yeah, corn.
Corn is the meta.
They nerfed cheese.
Wait, you got to right click again, though, I think, to
change your baby.
Yeah, there you go.
Cheese got nerfed.
Alright, there we go.
The corn meta strat.
We're going meta now.
That guy can't like cheese and corn.
Yeah, there's no way.
Alright, that has to be...
Oh.
Oh my god!
Throw it back.
He can and he will it says common carp not common blue kill
this is it this is the one this has to be the one this is
the one this is the one oh he's like frisky yeah this is the
one yeah he didn't he doesn't want to be caught i'm keeping
it i'm keeping i don't care i don't care how many is it mike
why don't you catch fish Why don't you catch two for us,
huh?
They should nerf the bluegill spawn rate.
They have like, they are an invasive species.
They're invasive species.
Send in the cats.
This is the one.
This has to be the one.
How am I supposed to catch three of them?
Oh my god, there it is.
Oh my god, there you go.
One out of three.
That's how you do it.
Don't throw it.
They say wherever there's one carp, there's always more.
Is there?
Is there more?
There was 80 bluegills, though.
All right, here we go.
Surely we'll get another two.
Yeah, I believe.
Okay, here it is.
Here it is.
Hit.
Oh, this guy is slow.
He wants to be caught.
I don't think this is the carp.
Oh, it is!
It is!
Woo-hoo!
Just one more carp left.
You got this.
Oh, my God.
He was right.
Where there is one, there is more.
The carp have come and eaten the bluegills.
Wait, yeah, they came back.
They're like, this is our land.
This is our creek.
It's a fish war.
Yeah.
Oh, what did he get?
He got something, too.
Oh, there we go.
Three out of three.
All right, harp.
Looks like we got three carp.
We want to head back and throw these the oven for dinner all
right let's go let's go baby let's fucking go i don't know
about the we though i did not see three carbs from him i see
three fishes and they're all from me yeah but you have your
own bucket too right no he had no he was holding the also
there was like creepy music just did is somebody watching me
in the house who's watching me Creepy music.
Why is there creepy music?
Want some corn?
What?
Did you open those doors?
I just, I didn't close the doors.
Oh, well, I'm cleaning the fish.
Do you mind prepping the marinade?
Uh, I'm not sure how to do it.
Just take a bowl and throw in ginger paste, cooking oil,
black pepper, salt, Italian seasoning, pepper.
Someone screenshot that.
Oh, like, I don't know what to have.
It's very easy.
Here's a 80-step guide.
Oh, here it is.
Okay.
Papria.
Okay, that's not paprika.
Okay, I need salt.
Oh, yogurt, yogurt.
I know where I put the yogurt.
It's right that tiny one.
Yeah, yeah, I know where I put the yogurt.
It's okay.
Oh, black pepper.
Yeah, and then ginger garlic paste.
Is that?
Oh, that.
Yeah, there you go.
All right, and then Italian seasoning.
Apricot and olive oil.
Paprica.
Yeah, I saw red.
Oh, there we go.
Yeah, I'm so good.
The marinade is so delicious.
Oh.
It's like a cat that always lands on its feet.
Do you mind throwing the fish?
Throwing it or throwing the fish in the marinade in the
casserole while I chop these veggies?
Not it.
though.
Where did he put the fish?
Where did he put the... Oh, there it is.
You didn't even chop it.
What did he want you to throw it in the what?
He said throw it in the casserole.
This one.
Oh, okay.
Oh, I have to add the fish first.
Okay, marinate.
Oh, all the fishes?
Oh, two.
Two carp.
Oh, all the... Okay.
There we go.
And then veggies.
Oh, he's done.
could you add the veggies i read it needs to go for 30
minutes at 400.
all right i can do that okay look at that bon appetiti bon
appetiti bon appetiti
those carp are going to taste amazing i sure hope they don't
have mercury in them oh me too i hope they don't have any
worms those like worms worms yeah while we wait for cook for
it to we play some board games.
I saw some in the room next to the living room.
Which one?
Just grab whatever catches your eye.
Can't wait to see what you pick.
I saw some in the room next to the living room.
Alright, let me see.
That oven is so loud.
Why is the music still creepy?
Yeah, I know.
Somebody's watching us.
So here?
They said there was a board game in the living room.
Yeah, but there's something on the table.
What are you holding?
What am I holding?
I think it's just a bug.
Oh, oops.
In the room next to the living room?
That's the basement.
Yeah.
What?
Where are they?
Yeah, that's God.
In the room next.
Oh, this room?
Oh.
What a weird thing to say.
To the Ouija board.
Oh, Ouija board.
Yeah, that's why I saw that.
We both saw that.
Boys in the Dark, Unravel Secret Mysteries, Chess Tower
Stack.
Was it Catopoli?
Is that...
All right, I picked the Ouija board.
Is that a Ouija board?
Whoa.
Molly once told me how she contacted her dead grandma
through one of those boards.
Luigi board.
I can't stand her spiritual bullshit.
Oh my god, Mike.
Whoa.
Remember how that dude was acting weird about the basement?
What if we tried this down there?
You want us?
Oh, we got to contact the 60 plus year old woman in the
walls.
That's a great idea.
All right, let's do that.
Wait, before we do, I need...
Oh, wait, that's not the basement.
I need a pee.
All right.
Oh, okay.
I'll be down here.
You're going to leave me in the basement.
Yeah, I'm going to leave you in the basement.
I'll be right back.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, everybody always says Doki Bird always has to pee, don't
they?
Oh, she's not gone yet.
Oh, she's gone now.
Guys, I'm so sleepy.
I want a nap.
She does know that I have to go in like an hour and a half,
right, though?
For the concert.
Scaredy Bird, yeah.
Ooh, why is he looking at us like that, though?
He looks so creepy.
Will she wash her hands?
We should bet on it.
say, I'm gonna give her the benefit of the doubt.
I will say that she will wash her hands.
But maybe actually, you know what?
No, I think she won't wash her hands.
She won't, she won't.
She's gonna lie.
She is gonna lie.
She will lie.
That's Doki Lion Bird.
Yes, because she was reminded earlier.
She has to be reminded to wash her hands.
What is this?
is this she ripped on some mpc about not washing their hands
recently okay okay i think she will i think she will the
bird be lying i'm locking in i'm putting it into the super
chat dang wait i am actually gonna my i'm gonna turn turn on
my light though it's so dark in here i forgot that i had no
light on
She will crack under the pressure.
How can we ask, how can we prove it?
Go scare the dark.
Maybe.
I have like some lights or some, what's it called on though?
Some lamps on.
Did you wash your hands?
Well, you can tell I washed my hands.
It took me a while to be back.
Okay.
All right.
Child owes me five dollars.
Wait, why?
We bet on it.
You bet on...
You bet...
Oh, you bet that I will wash my hands?
Yeah.
That's a lie.
That's a fucking lie.
I bet you didn't.
I bet you did not.
No!
I said that you would!
I said I'm gonna give you the benefit of the doubt!
You would polymarket me that I would wash my hands.
What is that?
Oh, you don't know polymarket?
That's where...
You know how like everyone bets on everything now?
or like oh i think this yeah that's where they do it it was
one where my favorite one was like um people were like jesus
will come back before gta 6 came out of release oh who
what's which side is winning which side do you think was
winning jesus all right let's do the we jump award all right
it's pretty wow he's got to go into the darkest part yeah i
was gonna say the darkest part oh no he's just grabbing a
table okay what are we though oh oh you know what we'll make
this even spookier is he gonna tell you to turn off the
lights is he gonna turn them and turn off the lights what
now oh let's turn off all these lights oh my god we played
ourselves all right here we go i can't even see that we I
can't see you.
Anyway, do you know how this works?
Yeah, I'm a professional.
Some might say I'm being haunted right now.
Ooh.
Moo.
Are there any spirits who want to talk to us?
Ooh.
Okay, why is it just him holding it?
Yeah, he's...
He's just moving it.
It's not even spelling anything.
I don't think humans have this word.
What is the spelling?
I...
A?
What?
Yes.
Okay.
No way.
Are you moving it?
Dot, dot, dot.
Okay.
I got one too.
All right.
Go ahead.
Oh, is the afterlife treating?
you buddy dot dot dot okay m f no j mint phantom mf j why
didn't that's how you spell mint mf j no i what did she even
say what did she i know are you friendly I like the wiggly
text.
It really sells it.
Yeah, it really does.
You can tell exactly M.
Why does she love M so much?
A.
J.
E.
My.
What does she say?
What?
We cannot comprehend.
You cannot understand our ghost knowledge, our ghost words.
Come on, buddy.
Give us a sign.
Let us know you're here.
R.
E.
F.
Oh.
Holy crap!
What?
Mike just leaves me?
I'm not usually wanting to believe in ghosts or spirits.
I think there is someone living in these walls.
I think so.
It's just 60 plus.
Well, now we know that Mike will leave me behind.
Mike will leave you behind.
Yeah, Mike will leave.
What the hell was that, Mike?
Yeah, what the fuck was that, Mike?
There's some freaky sheesh going on down there.
Wait, this is like a parasite.
Have you ever watched the movie Parasite?
Yes, I love that movie.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's good.
The weird part is that you ditched me.
Yeah.
Tell him.
What the hell, Harp?
I figured you wouldn't move your ass, too.
Well, now he's guilty.
Oh, now he's guilt tripping me.
Well, it would have been nice if he looked behind, looked
back.
He didn't even do that.
Have you ever heard of fight or flight?
Kill this guy.
Sydney, I'm sorry.
Whatever.
I wish Nora was here.
Yeah.
Oh, our fish is done, I think.
Our fish is done.
Big L, dude.
I know.
That's an L.
Yeah, big L, dude.
Big L.
Big L, bro.
He's a big L.
Big loser.
You're the loser.
Loser, Mike.
Loser.
Sorry if your name is Mike in the chat.
Yeah.
I think our show is about to come on.
Do you want to watch TV while we eat?
Sure, and let's do it.
No, I want to take the fish upstairs to my bedroom.
He just took that out with his bare hands.
I think he's like a monster.
And he was the ghost all alive.
My name is Mike.
You're the cool Mike.
You're the cooler Mike.
All right, this Mike does not represent all mics.
No, this Mike is just...
from the yeah he is banished from the mic council yeah we we
don't own this mic yeah oh how to banish him no no more tv
oh my god what the is this by the way i have to go in an
hour and a half a mayonnaise water park a mayonnaise water
park we are going to prepare the asparagus season these
Salt is good for the bones.
It's my favorite show, Mint.
Yeah, what is this?
Which one is this?
It's like a Gordon Ramsay.
But like, he's even... Look at him.
You take a couple cocoa peas.
Mmm, yummy.
Are you learning?
Are you learning, Mint?
I am.
The next thing we prepare is the mayonnaise.
Ooh, the mayonnaise.
Why do you start frying the mayonnaise?
No, it's the next...
They're making sauce!
It's cocoa, beans, and mayo.
I was dumb with it.
Harp, that was some damn fine food.
It was as good since we caught the fish ourselves.
It was alright.
Yeah, it was alright.
You don't have to rain on my parade, Harp.
It was no Moe's pizza, but I thought it turned out well.
Damn, Moe's must have been amazing.
Yeah, Moe's pizza must have been so good.
I mean, there's that guy that's been here since 85.
Yeah.
Anyways.
I need to check my emails real quick.
Left my laptop upstairs.
I thought we were taking a break from work, Mike.
It's not work.
I'm waiting on shipment details for my new DS.
My new DS.
I'll be right back.
I'll clean up here.
It's time to clean up, right?
time to clean up gasoline wait what robin with mayo almost
like a high-end cleanse oh here i'll let you watch this
while i go get some more water okay just a little bit or
half and half do not use diesel why not diesel after letting
the gasoline come to a boil we can put in our ramen oh ramen
and my basement but you can use whatever kind you like this
ramen will taste fantastic once the gasoline fully soaks
into the noodles it's actually kind of scientific bill nai
who the gasoline molecules merge with the That sounds very
scientific.
See, it's just like Gordon Ramsay.
If your oven catches on fire, make sure you know the usual.
With the fire extinguisher.
Well, damn.
Damn, that's burnt.
I'm not eating this.
But not to worry.
It's okay, he just made a little mistake.
Who's gonna eat him?
What?
No, I made you food!
What the fuck?
No, no, no, it's not poison.
It's not poison.
Hey, it's just made with gasoline, Grandma!
Goodbye, Grandma!
Stay in your room!
I don't want you watering around the house again!
It's literally Hell's Kitchen, true.
It is.
Do you think he'll let us put it...
Do you think if we submit an ad for him, he'll put it on TV?
I guess we can still enjoy our gasoline vibe.
will be in the next game any means possible.
Any means necessary.
We'll handle everything.
Cooking with Jeffrey.
Oh, the show, I can't remember.
The show's over.
Let's go.
No, the show just started.
No, no, no.
The show's just started.
Look, see?
The show just started.
No, the show is over.
The show is over.
You know what?
We should submit our own ad.
We should.
That was exactly like one of the commercials that we saw.
Yeah, we just saw that.
They're just for eating stuff.
Alright.
Where's the trash?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, I cleaned.
Okay.
Oh, there you go.
There, I'm washing the dishes.
You're dishwashing.
Yeah, I'm putting those fish into the sink.
How much you want to bet someone will be out the window?
They're like,
Woo-go-boo-boo-boo-boo-boo-boo-boo-boo-boo-boo.
We've played this game before.
You can't bet on it if you already know.
Okay, I played it over a year ago.
It was a very long time.
It was like two years ago.
Wait, this game is two years old?
I think so.
I did the dishes.
Where the fuck is Mike?
Upstairs.
It's on TV.
No, no, no, no.
Mike.
Why is he?
What?
Oh, he's fucking with me.
He's fucking with me.
There's no way.
Why would there be someone under the bed, Mike?
Yeah, that would be so stupid.
Nice.
I'm not.
I don't care.
it's him he's under the bed yeah he's the one under the bed
oh my god that was yeah he's like walk slow and i like
fucking run up to the door i liked how the jump scare was
also like super slow i know it was actually come on come on
mate yeah yeah you definitely got me mate we were so You're
so scared.
You're so scared.
That was fun, wasn't it?
Whatever.
Come on, it was just a joke.
You want to go for a next round?
Next round of what?
Yeah, next round of what?
How about a game of hide and seek?
A game of hide?
Mike, we are adults.
You want to play Mecha Chameleon?
No, Mecha Chameleon.
You want to play more Mecha Chameleon?
or i hide but we literally played that game we're adults
yeah but that's a video game that's different oh i decided
the basement i had a feeling i was gonna be in the basement
i know why would you choose that though all right oh geez so
your tv's on and i'll turn on the lights yeah my perfect Oh.
A nook under the stairs.
Oh, your mic is on.
Can
you hear me?
You didn't mute me, did you?
Look at your breathing.
Come on now.
I would not hide under here.
It would be so dusty and full of spiders.
Disgustin.
Say something, I dare you.
Oh.
Oh, he looks like a killer for real.
I got you.
Got you.
That wasn't even a challenge.
I figured you wouldn't be good at this since I never find
you in the city.
Why are we playing hide and seek in the city?
What are we doing?
It's just like, you know, Saturday we do a pot and seek.
Oh, it's his turn.
Alright.
Well, I'm not counting it.
I'm not counting in the basement.
No, I'm going up.
Oh, yeah, yeah, that's true.
Oh, I have to.
It won't let you!
It's okay.
I'll look at the door.
Yeah.
One Mississippi.
Oh, you have to...
Mississippi.
Just click through them, yeah.
Five, six, seven, eight, nine, nine, nine, nine, nine.
Right now, here I come!
Here I come!
Alright.
He has to be in the bedroom, right?
Oh.
Bum.
Oh, the doors are shut.
Oh, that's true.
It's shut in the bedroom.
Maybe he's late.
Oh, I didn't like that.
Look at the yard?
Did you see the yard?
What?
Oh.
Sorry, I thought I saw someone.
No, there wasn't anyone there.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Oh, that scared me.
Ooh.
Ooh, spooky.
Maybe he's hiding in the shower.
The Amazonian shower.
Oh, he's not here.
Why is the music so creepy?
Um, tick, dock, tick, dock.
Oh, he's not here in his living room?
Where will he hide here?
uh and there's a there's the room where you got the the
stuff yeah board game stuff yeah seeing that no where is
this guy this house is not that big the shed outside you
think he actually went outside oh he could have um um see i
didn't close any of the doors so like He painted it.
He what?
He painted himself.
He's like, yeah, we're playing metcha chameleon now.
We're playing metcha chameleon.
Is he in the painting?
Is he?
Is it the painting map?
Do you mind?
Oh, there he is.
Got you.
Hang on, harp.
I think I heard something upstairs.
upstairs for once shame on you fool me twice no kidding
Sydney I really heard something sliding up there you didn't
hear it no I did not I swear in my life I heard something
well I see this attic access door in here oh here oh step
stool wait you see what
You see how the mic picks up over in there?
Uh-oh.
You gotta be quiet.
Ooh.
Oh, not here.
Not here, though.
Wait, why isn't Mike coming with me?
Mike?
I know, Ryan.
What the hell?
Mike!
That's, I'm grabbing the flashlight.
Yeah, you probably want the flashlight, too.
Yeah, I'm grabbing the...
Fuck this, bro.
Fuck Mike.
There we go.
There you go, yeah.
Yeah, you know what you could have done, Mike?
Help me grab the flashlight.
Shining in his face so he goes blind.
You're right.
That's right, Mike.
That's right.
You'll never see again.
He's such a coward.
I know.
Oh, that's a little spooky.
Oh, there's the cat.
Cat!
Hey, there.
Little baby.
Oh, you can pet the cat.
You can pet the cat.
So cute!
Hello, little cat!
Yeah, why is there a bed up here?
Wait, you're right.
Which bed is this?
Alright, it was a cat all along.
You were fucking scared of a cat!
Maybe bring the cat back down?
Like...
Sydney, are you okay?
What was up there?
Looks like you aren't the only pussy in the house.
Ooh, that's a good one.
I like that.
Ooh, that is a good one.
That is a good one.
That is a good one, Sydney.
Yeah.
snaps there it was just a cat it was just a cat oh that's a
relief i was worried there for a minute i think she was
hugged are you ready to count again let's let's go round two
yeah i think it was your turn all right wait what about
we're just gonna leave the cat they're like the option was
feed the cat or we keep going with hide and seek They're
like serious about their hiding.
Oh, the tool shed.
Okay, you do hide in the tool shed.
Yeah.
Alright.
Hide in the tool shed.
So creepy.
Wait, you can look out the window.
There's the other one on the other side too.
Yeah, that one.
Am I hiding?
I can't tell.
I think so.
I don't know.
They're not very good hiders, I feel like.
Yeah.
Like, I don't know if I'm hiding.
Am I doing it?
Oh.
Oh, oh.
There he is.
Oh, he's coming.
He's coming.
Oh, my God.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, he's stupid.
Dude, so we're going to run up here and stab him or
something.
Is that what's...
Wait, that'd be crazy.
Finally, all I'm doing is finally Mike is gone.
Someone just runs up and goes cha-cha.
Yeah There's a quick one two and then runs away.
He can't even see us.
It's so stupid.
My god, where could I be hiding?
Where could we be?
Oh, oh, there I am.
There you are.
Damn harp.
It took me a while.
to figure out you left the house.
Anything worth doing is worth doing well.
My turn.
Close those pretty eyes now.
I'm getting tired.
Look, I'll hide in the house.
We're headed back anyway.
You find me and we'll go to bed.
What about, no, what about Nora?
Oh yeah, what happened to Nora?
Nora's still not here.
I guess she'll drive tomorrow?
Where did my flashlight go?
Oh, it's here.
It's right there, yeah, yeah.
I feel like that's gonna be important.
All right, why did you close the door?
Oh, Mike was hiding.
Okay.
All right, here we go.
All right Well, Mrs. One two three five.
I'm here
All right.
Where could he be?
Not here?
It should be somewhere where the door is closed, you know?
You think he would hide in the basement?
No, he's too baby.
You're right.
He's a little baby.
Your noise is in the basement.
Rant.
There's like two rooms to hide in here, though.
Wait, nothing is closed.
Yeah.
Oh, bathroom.
Oh, oh, oh.
Ah!
The scream is so funny.
Woo!
What's going on?
What happened?
Well, hey there.
Oh.
He was fixing the sink.
He said he was going to fix it.
That I did say.
Rick, why aren't you back?
Why are you back?
I'm fixing the faucet.
You got a problem with that?
He did tell us, though.
He was getting...
Well, I don't know.
I know.
I remember.
He said, I'll come back to fix it.
Don't worry.
I've never seen anyone fix a faucet with a hammer before.
How do you know, Mike?
You never fix it?
many faucets yourself young man didn't think so so imagine
you don't know what tools you need i was gonna say i don't
think mikey would know how to fix the sink right isn't it
late though yeah why is he still here for you no trouble for
me at all miss he needs that five star review bro he does he
does he only has he has two reviews and they're both three
stars and less i told you i'll get that suit sink fixed for
you real soon uh do you think we could maybe fix it to
tomorrow?
Yeah.
You're asking me to leave, Miss?
Well, yeah, because we're renting the place.
Yeah.
No, Rick.
She's being polite.
We rented this house and would like to have it to ourselves.
We don't really want to have to call law enforcement.
Mike, please.
Let me handle this.
Mike, you're escalating the situation.
Mike, you're escalating the situation right now.
I did not mention anything about cops.
Yeah.
Ain't no cops.
Oh!
What?
Ain't no cops in Woodbury, son.
You think they're gonna arrest the homeowner for fixing the
faucet?
I was just doing some work.
If you can't handle that, it's your problem.
Not mine.
You know what?
I think Mike escalates way too fast.
He dies?
I know.
He escalates so fast and then they get mad at us.
It didn't matter me.
Yeah, I was like, what did I do?
Why fuck me for?
Yeah.
If folks don't like fixing the faucet, I'll leave you to it.
Wait, is Mike?
Mike was like behind the door.
And stay out.
Yeah, stay out.
I'll give you a one-star review.
You won't like that, would you?
You can't be mean to us because you're dependent on our
reviews.
Exactly.
Unless they have, they review us too.
Then that might be a problem.
That might be a problem.
Like a B&B.
Yeah, we're fine.
We're fine.
Customer is always right.
Yeah, customers are always right.
I think the water might be cold or something because we have
to go down to reboot their water heater.
After locking the door, we debated what to do.
We agreed that there's something off about Rick from the
start.
It seemed like he joined making excuses to come over and
now...
He just came over once.
right yeah he is like um he seems to be making so many
excuses i can't stand this guy i can't see one is too many
in the end we decide rick was weird but probably harmless we
attributed this behavior to extreme lack of social oh my god
imagine you're rick right now because it's based off a true
slander yeah he's like i thought i was a nice guy Yeah,
yeah.
He's like playing this game.
He's like, this reminds me of the time I fixed that person's
sink.
Yeah.
I'm a homeowner that rents their stuff for Airbnb.
Oh, let's check it out.
Yeah, look, we're each all the way out here.
Let's just enjoy ourselves, Mike said.
By this time, I was feeling really tired.
I decided to get some rest.
Where is Nora?
It's almost gone.
Yeah, where's Nora?
Is she not coming?
Oh, I'm feeling a little groggy.
Oh, you're still got your flashlight, though.
I got my flashlight, though.
Wait, was that a knock?
Ew.
Oh, yeah, I was like, I was showing it.
I was like, why is he still all black?
Harp, are you still awake?
Hard to sleep when someone's knocking on the door.
Do you mind if I come in?
I'd like to talk about something.
What the hell?
We're asleep, man.
Yeah.
Why are you wake us up?
the storm is getting starting to get really bad I can hardly
see the truck in the driveway Nora oh Nora's okay I hate a
Nora's out there all alone yeah she'll be fine Sydney don't
worry I'm here to keep oh my god oh what oh we're talking
about Nora yeah I know I was like not this guy what what hey
it's no problem at all guys are supposed to watch over
people they care about right he's making his move right now
time and place mike time and place he's like acting like an
edgy anime protagonist staring out the window he's very
chunny right now what a day huh this wasn't exactly how i
thought our getaway was going to go sydney i know right it's
been a strange yeah it's been a strange day can you believe
that guy he just keeps wandering around the house like he
owns the he doesn't know exactly when i met sidney he
shouldn't just barge in this place whenever he wants we
rented the damn house i mean the guy is probably harmless
but i'm frustrated you've also been a little difficult i'm
worried what do we send mikey off the edge though we might
we might
Oh, nice.
Okay, we got...
Okay, nice.
You're right, Sydney.
I'm really sorry.
Oh, wow.
He... Okay.
Maybe good ending.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Good ending.
It's alright.
It's okay.
Yeah, it's okay.
It's alright.
At least you know.
At least you know, you know, you know.
Yeah, yeah.
You admit it.
That's fine.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, okay.
That's my bed.
Oh.
Why don't you come sit by me, Sydney?
Okay.
I don't want to do that.
Okay, Mikey.
He's gonna try and kiss you.
Oh, God.
harp you know yeah i don't know i don't know i don't want to
know i've missed this us playing hide-and-seek in the city
and catching fish and us just talking it's been too what you
mean we talked last week with nora yeah when nora was there
we're the three musketeers yeah we're three musketeers what
do you mean yeah you know you don't have to sleep below
tonight if you don't want them would you be doing this if
Nora was here oh my god where's our third wheel where is she
all right we need Nora we need you with a buffer we need it
please we need you what do I say Ben what do I say this
would you be doing this if dora was here oh can
you leave oh you act like you don't remember a trip to
oregon oh oh wait what happened in oregon oh yeah i do
remember it really well oh yeah to tell i remember it being
pretty awkward did it start out awkward though oh oh they
hooked up they hooked up they hooked up and then she was
like never never again never again oh i mean that was bike
that was bike oh dora dora and oh sos i sure did i'm hoping
maybe they can happen again oh wow oh no dora help SOS We
should help Nora instead
You just let me worry about the Nora says SOS Our friend is
in distress.
Yeah
What is it?
What did she say?
Oh
No, Lily Peach you
not good with the snowstorm out there too yeah yeah mike
instead of us sitting on the bed we should be helping nora
she wait like that's did she say 70 miles yes 70 miles yeah
she's like come come pick me up i'm 70 miles away yeah come
come drive your car into the snowstorm by the way guys how
long has she been driving for to be 70 miles away right she
just started like she's just outside the city like she's
like still in the city by the way what timing huh but i
guess we i guess we can't leave norah stranded then we can't
we better get ready no sydney you stay here and get some
sleep there's no sense in both of us freezing our asses off
i want to save norah no are you sure
Yeah, I'm sure you're in pajamas.
Wait, I mean, he wasn't sleeping Yeah, he just settled in
and I'll go help Nora.
Yeah, what the fuck was he doing?
He wasn't sleeping sleeping the entire time That's like a
two-hour drive people are saying so that's like but that's
but then add the snowstorm Yeah, add the snowstorm.
It'll be like five hours.
Yeah Oh, please be careful.
I was like doing nice things for you.
You may do nice things for Nora This is, we're trying to
see...
Yeah, this is not for us.
This is the same friend.
Our friend, by the way, Mikey.
Our friend!
Oh my god.
Please be careful.
It would be for me.
That's our friend.
I would not be able to sleep.
I don't want to be alone in this house.
I know, right?
We'll finish talking about this later, okay?
Get some good rest and sleep.
stay warm you feel like we have to all right okay oh lock
the front door that's smart he locked like when he locked
the front door yeah that's yeah like oh there he goes bye
mike bye uh are you sure it's saved to drive yeah oh i just
opened the door i'm driven in horse it's so loud yeah
besides norah's probably freaking out more than you right
now probably right yeah because she's trapped in a snowstorm
trap the snowstorm in her car in her car make sure you take
care of yourself all right lock all the doors is that like
my dad oh maybe he'll like that i should have Yeah, blame
me.
I know, right?
Yeah.
How about a hug?
I gotta need one right now.
I should go sleep now.
No, I should hug him just because, like, I'm scared.
Nah.
Oh, it's too late.
Sweet dreams.
Get some sleep, Sydney.
Alright.
Let's go back.
You're nicer than I am.
I go back to bed.
I'd be like, good night.
So maybe locking all the doors is not a good thing, though,
if the guy is inside the house.
I told myself things would get better if I could just get
some rest.
Nora always knew how to cheer me up.
Like, I was like, always Nora, not, like, no mention of
Mikey.
Yeah, screw Mikey.
We were arriving soon.
I decided to rest in the meantime.
i'm gonna wake up soon asterisk like it's a one hour later
oh pizza delivery mo's got pizza he ordered mo's for us oh
that's so kind of him yeah you know see this is why i gave
him a hug so he ordered me pizza
huh oh it's the hitchhiker the hitchhiker it's the
hitchhiker Please open the door.
I'm freezing to death out here.
Wait, how did he know he followed our...
How did he know he couldn't follow my car?
You crashed like so many times.
There's no way.
Oh.
I'm going to open the door.
You will?
I've no sense of survival.
No survival.
Well, we were going to get him in our car anyway.
Just let him in the house.
house too yeah hello if you're cold he's cold look friend i
know it ain't ideal banging on your door in the middle of
the night but i'm in a bad spot here yeah mikey's not here
to stop me i was carrying on a ride from some friends but
they were running behind and won't be here for about two
more hours you're not coming in end the story you sit on the
porch where's the let let him in Why can't I let him in?
Let him in.
Oh, she does not want him in.
Thanks, but I was hoping you let me wait inside until my
friends get here to get me.
You're not coming in.
End of story.
Oh, are you fucking kidding me?
You're going to let me freeze to death out here?
I make you go hiking in the snowstorm.
Yeah.
I should know you'd be a big, as you'd be as big.
being a bitch here as you were back.
I said to let him sit with us.
In the car.
He could be a vampire.
Yeah, you're right.
He can't let him in.
He'll suck our blood.
Yeah, he has to be invited, though.
You didn't think I see you and your little boyfriend fishing
in the creakle?
I think you may give me a chance this time, but it looks
like you're still unkind.
Please just leave her.
No, I say.
Get out or call the cops.
Yeah, get out or call the cops.
Be mean to them.
There's no cops.
How are there no cops around here?
Yeah, how does he know?
Ain't no cops around here.
Speaking of, I don't see your fella's truck out here either.
I'm dialing 911 now.
Fine.
Suit yourself.
Is he going to leave or?
He's going to leave?
Can I open the door for him?
Oh, there he goes.
Bye.
I mean, you just sit in the porch.
Didn't you say you want to sit in the porch?
Is there a...
Oh.
Let me tell you something.
You get what's coming to you for leaving me out here.
Karma's a bitch, my friend.
Karma's a bitch.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
Is that the JoJo's evil?
Yeah, karma's a bitch.
I was going to say, is there like a phone to call the cops?
Alright, time to sleep.
Apparently JoJo Siwa had a cruise and it looked really fun.
Had a cruise?
Like the JoJo Siwa cruise?
I think like she like had a...
Can I go back to sleep?
I think so.
Oh, oh Who's that that was right next to you?
Yeah.
Oh, the violence going crazy right now.
Yeah, the violence going crazy
Call for help what happened out there what happened
Eric, I'm sorry about it again, but can come oh now I want
him over I just make all to be fair I've done like I did
this to myself, you know honestly yeah yeah someone met
driving down here he was banging on the door and started
throwing me i'm pretty scared and i think i hear him moving
around outside like i could just let him stay there for like
an extra 30 minutes to fix the faucet like all
right i texted him oh you yeah call for help though like why
isn't she calling for help in her with her phone do you have
any new messages don't oh wait that's when he did the hide
and seek maybe you sit in the closet how do i i have my cell
phone can i not call from my cell phone like maybe it's a
call from a landline oh oh the the what's his name is here
it might be oh i think so it could be it could be a rick
yeah yeah oh there he is why does he have
Wait a minute.
You'll open the door.
Hey.
What the hell's going on there?
Did you see anyone outside?
I might have seen something.
Yeah, what was it?
I killed him.
Who screamed?
Yeah, who was the one screaming?
Could have been anyone.
Or no one at all.
What does that mean?
Yeah, what does that mean?
Yeah, I came as quickly as I could.
I wouldn't worry about him anymore.
Oh.
Oh, and he's smiling when he says that, too.
Yeah, he's smiling.
He's like, about that sink.
Yeah, about that sink.
Let me check that for blood.
Yeah, I'll check it out.
By the way, where's your friend?
The guy who was with you earlier.
He's still here.
He's, like, sleeping.
Yeah, he's still here.
He's still here.
There's two people in this house.
He's a deep sleeper.
I'm not alone in the house right now.
I'm not alone.
I'm not a single woman right here alone in this house Yeah,
I'll be like he should be back soon Yeah Yeah, all alone
here right now Yeah, but my friends will be back soon They
went to go but most pizza most pizza.
You know it's famous.
There's like five five minutes.
Well, you know how close most pizza is We were starving.
A little midnight snack.
Oh, my gosh.
Why didn't he leave?
Why is he here?
He's going to watch.
Oh, he's going to warm up.
Why is he looking at us like this?
Storms like this brings all kinds of folks.
Not all know when to stay away.
Oh, I also don't know when to stay away.
Why are you still here?
Oh.
Uh-oh.
Then who was Ford?
Still there, feel safe opening that door?
You might want to run.
Hey!
Oh, he's a squatter.
Everything okay!
Awfully for texting, isn't it?
Who are you talking to?
My friends!
It's my friends!
They're almost there!
Is that so?
Uh...
Yeah, thanks for goodbye.
I'll be fine now.
You can head back.
Yeah, I just overreacted.
Who?
Wait, wait, I can just pretend that I'll be done.
You need to leave right now.
What did you say?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, this is my fucking house.
I will leave what I want to.
What do you want?
Yeah, what do you want?
I want what's mine.
This house and you...
Stranger Danger!
What are you doing?
We rented it!
I don't think so.
If anyone's leaving this house, it would be one of us.
Oh, what?
What?
Oh!
He gave you a chance I think we might be What?
It should let you go back to that Okay, okay Yeah, yeah,
yeah I was like, what happened?
He just He owns the door This is why we gotta get rid of
squatter rights, guys This is why He's a squatter all right
he was in the attic yeah that was his bed
oh maybe like stay by you know oh it's dark stay by the the
staircase maybe or yeah do i have to go where do i go do i
go to the basement there's the hiding spot in the basement
the hiding spot in the oh yeah yeah there's two of them turn
on lights oh i like how Now it's fully done.
You have to go through the whole sequence.
That's annoying.
Yeah.
Well, keep the doors open.
Yeah, keep the doors open.
Keep the doors open.
Oh, God.
There he is.
Oh, he walks through doors.
That's why he could get you from outside.
Maybe he'll talk to me here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right.
And then I'll have, like, I can...
you're not rich are you did he just say oh
oh okay is
that it
is that him coming down
oh what's that saying oh what's going on
oh he's gonna get you wait is he looking right at you
always gonna come get you he's gonna come get he's gotta run
back he's gonna rip open the door.
Oh.
Oh, you can run.
Go, go, go, go.
No!
Oh, God.
It's not my fault, Nora.
I made me do a three... Why did she do that?
Nora, you bitch.
Oh, you stop.
Wait, you have to go through the whole sequence again.
Okay, no.
That's fine.
Now you're good.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Go, go!
Oh my god, they're gonna get you killed.
I don't know.
He immediately went, huh?
Oh my god.
Height shamed.
Actually, what's up with this?
Okay
Oh my god
I'm just going to the shed.
I'm going to the fucking tool shed.
No, don't go to the shed just go just hide in there and
don't say anything Okay, okay, okay.
Yeah
No, he wouldn't.
What do you do now, though?
You think you run downstairs?
Would it be funny if Nora texted me there while I was in
there?
Oh my god You got your fucking bitch
Goodbye I was like, it wouldn't be so funny No, we have to
do the basement again
No, what if you, um, when you leave
What if when you leave, you, um Prep the stool or something.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, you're dead.
You're dead.
You're so dead.
No!
Shit!
Alright, this side.
This side.
He does also have to, like, break into the room when you
shut the door, so maybe you can grab the thing then.
The step stool.
It takes too long to grab, maybe.
Oh.
You would think she puts her phone on mute now.
Doki is locked in.
Oh, yeah, wait until the bell...
Yeah.
Don't make Doki laugh.
Oh, she's safe now, though.
Okay.
Okay, we're safe.
Oh.
Oh!
Is that it?
I don't know.
I don't know either.
He heard you though.
Yeah, he did.
I don't know if I can come for peace.
I don't know either.
What do you do?
What do I do?
Come on, Nara.
Do you think it's weird?
Why did he heard it though?
He heard it.
I was like, eh?
Yeah, he did the thing.
why don't you text anyone help save me i don't know like why
is she so stupid oh that that's stuck oh dang those those
cell phones that are only one way texting damn the reception
here must be really really bad real bad i'm scared to go
down if you go down oh oh the cat Where's the cat?
Oh.
What?
Are they yelling for you?
Oh!
You just have to wait.
Oh.
Maybe it's fine.
Go, Rick.
It sucks because you don't want to have to do the...
The whole thing again.
Yeah.
The basement and stuff.
of everything again you heard the cat maybe it's fine all
right down I go here we go down I go if oh it was open
oh oh the door is busted oh I'm walking very slowly.
I assume I don't have to run anymore.
They're trying to bust down the door.
Oh, he left through the back door.
Oh, sheesh.
Yeah.
Yay!
I told him everything that happened after Mike had left.
Rick had called the cops.
The storm had quieted down by the time they arrived.
Oh, good.
And of course, the man was nowhere to be seen.
So what happened to the hitchhiker?
I think he died.
We heard that guy go, oh, yeah.
We just forget about him?
I think so.
And also there was a dead guy, but we don't talk about that
part.
Well, he was a creepy guy anyway, so we're just like, yeah,
screw you, screw you.
Alright, I drive back the whole now he was like, karma's
gonna get you.
Karma's a bee.
Yeah.
I gotta getcha I don't even know so much of that song Wait I
just literally say One line of the song Secret Jojo Siwa
Super fan here guys We think that the man we secretly We saw
secretly live in that cabin when it wasn't being used Yeah
it was a squatty And Panna robbing us during our stay Those
cops seems to be thinking there was more intent behind this
man's action Aside from just robbing us Oh my god what the
fuck was he gonna do yeah Rick asked me what the man looked
like and after that he didn't ask any more questions I think
he knew more than he was letting on oh he he knows that guy
it's not this first time but in the end he gave us a full
refund that's why it was two stars
it's probably like his cousin or something yeah his cousin's
squatting Yeah.
Yippee!
What the fuck is going on over here?
Yeah, see Lily Peachy!
Oh, Dante!
Who's Dante?
I don't know if I recognize that name.
Oh.
I was like, I know, I've seen that name before.
Oh, they're checking the basement, yeah.
Oh, see if he's there.
Oh, there's the cops.
Oh, yeah.
There he is.
This is actual Sims music.
We're playing the Sims.
Look at that.
We made it just in time before Batara's concert too.
We did it.
Wait, top supporters?
Wait, Lily Petru is also going to be in that concert.
Isn't that crazy?
Oh yeah, that's crazy.
Yeah.
Wait a minute.
There's a top supporters.
Is there actually a Patreon?
Wait, I'm looking it up.
I'm looking it up.
Look it up.
Here is to Fathom Patreon.
They said top supporting.
How are they able to support them?
Wait, but it says last posted.
2024.
2020.
Well, this game was two years ago.
Oh, wait, no.
2025.
Wait, there is a Patreon.
What are the perks?
I'm looking.
I can't.
Wait, how do I see what the perks are?
Fears to...
It says iron.
Okay.
Wait, what?
Fears.
to the mason scale is that his that's no that's just a
review that's just him reviewing games oh wait are you sure
yeah oh okay yeah there's like this is my review of fears
the fathom wait i'm gonna see oh okay i'm gonna see why why
is their top supporter then is it like maybe in the discord
server oh maybe in the discord there's also merch That's
yeah, but then yeah, but then there's like your connection
is not private to this.
I don't want to go.
I'm sorry No, I clicked out of it to it.
Wait, oh my gosh, we could just message him on Twitter.
That's wait, what's the Twitter?
Here I'll send it to you.
What's the Twitter?
the rail rail All right, let's all let's both of us add him
and be like we love your we love you.
I'm following him I'm gonna follow him and then we add him
be like we love your game Hey, check your emails.
Dude, okay, okay, what should we write?
I'm going to add him.
I'm not adding you.
You're not adding coward.
You're a cow.
You should reply under it.
I'll reply under yours.
Okay, okay, yeah.
We love your games and cannot wait for the next installment.
Mint, Fatome, and I...
That's awesome.
I sent...
Mint Phantoma and I sent a story over.
You might want to read it.
Are you actually sending that?
We would love to voice act for your game for free.
Stop acting like an extrovert.
Wait, no, yeah.
I will say I'd love to voice act.
Yeah.
Let's do it.
In any role, you will, we will even, even if it's one line.
And then we can be like, find, find which character, wait,
wait, what do we say?
We'll record like a, a commercial.
We'll even record a commercial for you.
Like we could record ourselves, like just kind of making a
skit.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right, Alright, you reply under that.
You reply.
I'm going to say sorry for my friend's desperation.
You are part of this.
You're complicit to this.
Follow the guy first before.
Desperate.
Wait, I don't see your tweet.
Oh, no, no, I already tweeted.
Follow him, too.
You got to follow him as well.
Okay, I'll follow him.
Where's your tweet, though?
Oh, here we go.
Oh, you added him.
Yeah, I added.
I could do a dot add.
So it shows up on my Twitter profile.
Should I do that?
The dot at.
Wait, what do you mean?
If I do it, if I do a period and then the at, it'll show up
on my, it'll show up on everyone's feed.
Oh, is that how that works?
Yeah, that's how it works.
You want me to do that?
No, don't, don't bully the guy.
Don't peer for it.
There you go.
What should I say?
What should you say?
What?
a story over you might want to read it it's a real thriller
winky face but if you want us in a commercial we can come up
with something really awesome we're great sales ladies my
business email is in my bio actually no i'll just say i'll
say uh wait uh what's here wait you sent it from your
business email yeah yeah i said from my business you're
coming guys are coming out so that's exactly what we're
trying to that maybe sorry that we reek of desperation but
we are desperate we are because we are here i'm gonna do a
silly emoji like Like, oh, I'm quirky, you know, like, yeah,
like, we're pretty, we're silly gals.
We're just silly gals, you know.
There we go, okay.
There we go.
I don't want to bully the poor guy.
Yeah, we're not, we're just, we're just having fun.
Yeah, yeah.
We're just having, we're just having fun, guys.
Use the Lenny face.
Oh, I should have.
Oh, you should, yes.
Yeah, that's, yeah.
It's fine That was fun That was a fun game We still have
Wait how many more This is the fifth installment Right so
there's four more Yeah I'm gonna retweet it No
I think the The multiplayer one was so fun though That
multiplayer one I feel like you should do more of those Yeah
Alright Next time we'll do the other fears The fathom games
guys I know like the first two They said it was really like
a really short right yeah they're all pretty short actually
like they're they're really good we didn't write a we didn't
write a real story a non-fiction story to the devs we would
finish this an hour ago with oh yeah 100 writing our real
we're retelling our very much very real story that happened
to the both of us yes it did it happened actually yeah true
story true story by the
Today we felt brave enough to finally tell you guys that
story.
I admit I have been in several walls of several homes.
Yeah.
I have a problem.
She does.
I'm not going to die.
Yeah, she does.
Yeah, I have a problem.
But thank you.
This was my therapy session.
Thank you, Mint, for hanging out with me today.
for fierce to fathom she's gonna be in a concert in like 20
minutes now crazy isn't that crazy?
she's gonna be in my concert too in two days in two days!
and I'll see you tomorrow for the panel oh yeah and I'm
gonna see her tomorrow at the panel too.
You guys didn't know sloppy sisters are gonna have a panel
at Anime Expo but if you're not there it's gonna be streamed
on YouTube and Twitch and they also told us we have to be PG
because it's gonna be streamed on youtube yeah oh yeah it's
on the anime expo yeah it's on the anime expo's official
twitch and youtube so you guys can catch our panel over
there tomorrow at 1 30 p.m pst guys so be there be sway i'm
double checking my yep i put that in my calendar yep you
tweeted it out too man i didn't tweet the times you're like
oh shit did i have something else
Thank you all for hanging out with us today, guys.
Thanks, everyone.
Bye, guys.
Yeah.
Have so much fun.
Bye-bye, everybody.
Bye-bye.